a swarm of bloodthirsty entities Waits
outside the protective boundary that
surrounds the solar system they surge
through the vacuum of space looking for
vulnerabilities in the force field that
protects us from their destructive
Powers the creatures ran themselves
against the barrier again and again
trying to break through upon impact the
force field shimmers a golden color and
displays a series of theurgical symbols
but it holds suddenly something flies
through the protective shield from
inside the solar system it leaves a hole
two creatures enter our solar system
before the shield closes this may be the
end for Humanity the sixth overseer sits
at a computer terminal massaging the
bridge of his nose he is just logged
into the foundation database to gather
information on an anomaly whose
intentions are still unknown the 05
Council wants him to vote on an extreme
measure but he requires more information
first there is something coming
he can feel it and he thinks it has
something to do with SCP
1548 0 5-6 straightens his back and sits
up in his chair he logs back into the
foundation database and brings up the
entry for SCP 1548 he knows that this
SCP has been connected to some odd
occurrences recently but what are its
true intentions is SCP 1548 trying to
help save the universe or is it a
malicious entity hellbent on destroying
it 0 5-6 must find out he Scrolls
through the first few entries SCP 1548
itself is a series of solar phenomena
that occur at the South Pole of the Sun
during these events the sun's plasma
morphs into different theurgical symbols
each symbol is tens of thousands of
miles across the symbols themselves have
not all been classified by the
foundation yet but there are three that
have been observed multiple times the
first is an unamed symbol that when
inscribed on a telescopic device by a
person with theurgical abilities can
identify psionic entities with malicious
intense the second symbol is known as
the calasian aisle which when displayed
on a material strengthens it immensely
and gives it the ability to absorb
kinetic and electromagnetic energy the
final symbol is the 12 holy owls of
synthium when this symbol is a fixed to
an object any entity that is killed by
it will immediately annihilate and take
everything thing in its radius with it 0
5-6 jots a note on the pad of paper
sitting on his desk he has seen some of
these symbols before they are connected
to the oran mythology the practitioners
of this religion are known as the Church
of the second HTH and are a mix of human
and alien entities whose main purpose is
to Aid the guardian deity of the
universe Raku leoen in combating any
threat that may try to wipe out this
existence there must be a connection
between the Church of the second highth
and SCP 1548 o 5-6 thinks he Scrolls
back through the SCP 1548 file to the
entry logged on May 17th 1983 the first
time an event connected to SCP 1548 was
recorded a pro picked up the
manifestation of theric symbols on the
South Pole of the sun it was odd but
nothing other than the manifestation of
the symbols seemed to occur this event
was recorded as extra normal event 908
and logged into the SCP database the
event was all but forgotten until
December 23rd 2016 when the activity of
SCP 1548 really began to pick up on that
day SCP 1548 began manifesting
protection symbols in Rapid succession
over the next few months a dense cloud
of ionized gas formed around the solar
system this ionized wall of radiation
surrounded the heliopause the boundary
where the sun's radiation gives way to
the vacuum of space over time this Cloud
became thicker until no light from
outside of the solar system could enter
Foundation censorship protocols were
quickly used to disseminate false data
suggesting that the solar system was
passing through a dense cloud of cosmic
dust and that was what was altering the
night sky and causing the Stars to
disappear but as 0 5-6 continues to scan
the files he knows what the true cause
of this phenomenon is it must be SCP
1548 but why is the anomaly trying to
protect us from something outside of our
solar system or is it trying to trap
Humanity within with no means of Escape
0 5-6 stands up and stretches Ah that's
enough for today he says out loud to the
empty room he walks towards the door and
reaches for the handle all of a sudden
Sirens start going off and red lights
begin to flash 0 5-6 spins around and
runs back to the computer terminal an
emergency alert begins coming through
the Falcon light 5 rocket that launched
earlier in the day to bring supplies to
the International Space Station has
spontaneously lost Lo 50% of its mass
mid-flight 0 5-6 frantically begins
typing he brings up videos from
surveillance satellites the overseer
watches in horror as pieces of debris
and bodies of the crew flow through the
Silence of space the rocket looks like
it has been cut directly down the middle
and half of the structure has vanished
from existence what is happening
suddenly another alert comes in all
communication has been lost with the
International Space Station without
warning the space station begins
broadcasting a series of Cognito hazards
0 5-6 quickly changes the channel to
stop the signal from transmitting
through his computer reports start
coming in from around the world that
anyone who continued listening to the
Cognito Hazard signals began entering
transes then their brain completely
evaporated from their skulls there is a
surge of theurgic particles in orbit
around the Earth 0 5-6 traces the
particles back to their Source they came
from SCP 1548 the signal from the ISS
stops abruptly the entire space station
changes course it is on a trajectory to
re-enter the Earth's atmosphere the
friction and heat will rip the space
station apart 0 5-6 can't believe what
is happening it seems as if SCP 1548
helped Humanity in a way by stopping the
signals from the ISS but how can he be
sure that SCP 1548 wasn't responsible
for the Cognito hazards in the first
place he needs more information 056
searches for answers as more anomalies
connected to SCP 1548 start occurring
around the world during a political
demonstration in Berlin a thaumaturgic
way opens up that leads to a pocket
Dimension soon after the appearance of
the portal koru Arch priest Farah atenis
the leader of the Church of the second
HTH makes an announcement he claims that
the way leads to a shelter which will
protect people from the coming Doom of
the universe the people in the area
along with the members of the Church of
the second HTH make their way into the
portal two undercover Foundation agents
follow follow the group after everyone
has entered the way immediately closes
and there is no further contact what
does the church of the second heo know
that we don't 0 5-6 wonders he continues
monitoring the situation and looking for
answers suddenly a message comes through
all Foundation channels it is coming
from the Sun it is not SCP
1548 instead it is SCP 179 the humanoid
permanently in space near the sun 179
sends out one clear word in its signal
defend who is scp-179 talking to 0 5-6
thinks what needs to be defended is it
Humanity our solar system the universe
another alarm begins to go off what now
0 5-6 screams he brings up the alert the
screen flashes to the Moon 0 5-6 focuses
in on where the alert is coming from it
is a foundation Base called area 32 what
remains left of the base is reporting
that SCP 2821 suddenly expanded in size
formed a wormhole that led to another
region of the universe and then vanished
through it taking 38 Foundation members
and 10 anomalies with it Sirens continue
to go off distress signals are being
picked up on every channel it seems as
if the world is coming to an end and
everything that is happening is somehow
connected to SCP 1548 a static field
transmission begins coming in from SCP 3
417 the words are Urgent all our Tans
here all our Tans must listen now the
stars are lost static breaks up the
transmission for a few moments before it
resumes ago the first Invasion occurred
the gods were unprepared never
comprehending the fragility of the
universe after its creation the worlds
must fight the transmission cuts off
everything goes silent a pulsating SCP
icon appears on the screen of 056 his
computer it is the part of the puzzle he
has been waiting for in 1999 the 05
Council unanimously voted to launch a
mission called serif 1 to explore beyond
the heliosphere and the mission's true
purpose was to explore the plausibility
of extraterrestrial SCP objects in Space
the message that 056 just received is
from serif 1 it is relaying information
back to Earth the video shows the
barrier of ionized radiation that SCP
1548 had created glowing orange at the
border of the heliopause the radioactive
wall seems to be made up of complex
geometric patterns around 6,000 M across
serapan accelerates towards the barrier
it smashes through the protective shell
the probe has entered Interstellar space
0 5-6 knows that everything he is seeing
is on a delay as the information being
sent back by serif one needs to travel
vast distances and it takes significant
time for signals to reach Earth after
passing through the ionized barrier the
connection to serif 1 is lost over the
next few days 0 5-6 tries to link the
anomalies happening in the solar system
to SCP 1548 the foundation still hasn't
concluded if 1548 is harmful or trying
to protect the solar system in some way
then a message comes in from serif 1 it
is briefly regained communication with
the foundation most of the probe's
instruments have been destroyed but its
rear-facing camera is still broadcast
casting 0 5-6 pulls up the feed he
stares at the screen in horror as the
images unfold before him the camera
captures swarms of unknown entities
surrounding the heliopause the bodies of
the entities are asymmetrical with
countless appendages and unknown
structures jutting out from their cores
they seem to range in size from 10 km to
10,000 km across although some seem so
large that their size can only be
hypothesized the Swarms crash into the
protective barrier that SCP 1548 has
created around the solar system each
time part of the swarm Rams the barrier
thousands of theric symbols and solar
flares appear at the point of impact two
entities that are later classified as
1548 Omega 1 and 1548 Omega 2 are
captured entering the solar system by
serif 1's camera video from serif 1
shows that as the probe exited through
the protective barrier it created a hole
that remained open for a few months
moments during the time that the shield
of ionized radiation was vulnerable 1548
omega-1 and 1548 oma-2 entered through
it they are now inside the solar system
SCP 1548 launches countermeasures in the
form of glowing red sigils that create
shock waves to slow down omega-1 and
Omega D2 omega-1 is shaped like an eel
with five contorted arms radiating from
its body and a mouth made of impossible
geometric shapes Omega D2 has a
tetrahedral structure that leaves a
trail of black rocks in its wake as the
two entities move towards the sun SC SCP
1548 becomes more active it closes the
hole in the barrier before any other
creatures of the Swarm can enter and
then launches hundreds of concentrated
blasts of thic energy at Omega D2 the
flares vaporize the entity in seconds
the last thing the video feed of sf-1
captures before it cuts out is omeg me-1
disappearing from view as it creeps
towards the center of the solar system
it has escaped the protective measures
of SCP
1548 after the 05 Council reviews the
footage they decide to deploy the scps
Cortana to intercept omega-1 the orbital
vessel is fully equipped with
experimental anomalous weapons and
propulsion systems the council assur
that the Cartana will be able to destroy
omega-1 data coming in from other
satellites indicate that omega-1 has
destroyed Pluto and other Kyper belt
objects it is slowly making its way to
the center of the solar system
annihilating everything in its path the
curana intercepts omega-1 near Jupiter
and engages the creature after 10
minutes of battling communication with
the ship is lost probes in the area
capture footage of the Cortana and
omega-1 in mid battle when they are
suddenly surrounded by a black substance
and both vanish from sight 0 5-6 and the
other council members watch in
anticipation unsure of what has just
happened then the black substance
dissipates the scps Cortana sits
Motionless In Space the entity is
nowhere to be seen a cheer erupts from
the overseers and Foundation members in
the room it seems the entity has been
defeated then without warning the
Cortana accelerates rapidly it is on a
collision course with Mars as the ship
hurdles past one of the probes in the
asteroid belt the foundation members see
an organic Mass resembling that of
omega-1 attached to the hole of the ship
the overseer Council watches in horror
as the scps Cartana smashes into the red
planet leaving a crater 250 M wide the
energy released from the impact
instantly ionizes the thin atmosphere of
Mars causing the surface to turn into
molten rock from the epicenter of the
impact crater a black organic Mass
begins to crawl across the planet the
overseers are frozen in fear but SCP
1548 immediately deals with the entity
that is devouring the surface of Mars
from the Sun comes the largest SCP 1548
instance ever recorded a solar flare is
jettison towards Mars the impact causes
a fusion reaction so intense that for a
moment Mars shines as brightly as the
sun the planet explodes its debris is
cast across the solar system over time
it will create a second asteroid belt in
the orbit that Mars once inhabited the
overseer council is now convinced that
the threat has been dealt with SCP 1548
is holding the Swarm at Bay outside of
the solar system at least for the moment
0 5-6 returns to his office he brings up
the file on SCP 1548 he is still unsure
of this scp's true intentions it seems
to be protecting Humanity but why 0 5-6
sits back in his chair and Scrolls to
the end of the file there is an update
to the file by 05- 3 something that
wasn't there before 0 5-6 opens the new
entry and reads the caption all that's
left of our infinite ever expanding
Universe 0 5-6 Scrolls down the image is
a picture taken by serif 1 before
contact was lost forever it is a picture
of All That Remains of the universe
there are two dots of light and nothing
else but Blackness the Swarm has
destroyed everything in the universe
except for those two far away Stars
and our own solar system which was
protected by SCP 1548 but how long can
it hold out against a universe
destroying Force only time will tell a
man is sitting in a chair inside a
containment cell at the SCP Foundation
the man is dressed normally and he isn't
trying to escape or attack the
researchers who are observing him the
only thing that makes this man different
from you or I is that he ages right in
front of us going from a teenager to an
old man in a matter of minutes at first
glance SCP 10007 looks very normal just
a corpse lying in a standard coffin well
the corpse of an old man in a coffin
being kept locked up in a containment
chamber is normal when compared to some
of the other strange anomalies that are
found in the SCP foundation's archives
inside the coffin with SCP 10007 is a
small Metal Key and this is quite
literally the key to seeing what makes
this anomaly so special on SCP 17's back
between his shoulder blades is a small
Keyhole x-ray scans of 17 have shown
that the keyhole is just an empty socket
it's unconnected to anything there's no
internal Clockwork mechanisms or other
Machinery that should be able to be
activated by a key when the metal key
that is kept in scp1000 7's coffin
classified as SCP
17-1 is inserted into the keyhole on
17's back and turned something truly
incredible happens as the key is turned
SCP 10007 undergoes a change unlike
anything the SCP Foundation has seen
before with each turn of the key the
subject's physical age is reversed by
one full year Foundation researchers are
able to watch one7 age in Reverse in
real time even any Decay that had set in
on the corpse is completely reversed and
disappears as the key is wound and 17
gets younger and younger as the key is
turned 17 will continue to Dage
physically compacting and shrinking down
until it appears to have the form of a
newborn human child it's unknown where
the physical mass of 17's body goes to
since this should defy the laws of
physics but those laws we assume to be a
Bedrock of our universe's reality are
often more of a suggestion when it comes
to anomalies the SCP Foundation deals
with Once SCP 10007 reaches the newborn
baby stage it will suddenly reactivate
coming to life immediately regardless of
how long it has been dead and lying in
its coffin once 17 is brought back to
life he will go through the entire human
life cycle within a 75-minute period
experiencing what looks to be
approximately one year of normal human
growth and development for every minute
that passes that means that in the
course of about 16 minutes researchers
will see SCP 10007 change from a crying
infant to a fully grown teenager as you
can imagine the subject has reported
feeling excruciating pain during these
first few minutes as his bones rapidly
lengthen and expand and his muscles
develop and change shape dramatically
SCP 10007 is able to watch with his
young eyes as his bones move and set
themselves into place lengthening and
widening in seconds during growth spurts
that normally take months or years after
about 5 minutes provided his legs have
grown to the same length at the same
time time he's usually able to prop
himself up and stand at around 10
minutes the pain really starts the bones
crack and ache as they grow at their
fastest for the whole cycle hair will
also grow on his face and body and he
can't help but feel some amount of Shame
and embarrassment at what's happening to
him in front of the foundation
researchers who are taking copious notes
by 20 minutes he can hardly think due to
the pain at this point he usually lies
down and curls into a ball whisper ering
to himself that it will all be over soon
that the pain won't last forever after
another 10 minutes he's right the pain
is almost stopped completely by the
30-minute mark But now as wrinkles and
stretch marks start to set in a
different kind of pain reveals itself as
SCP 10007 realizes that he must watch
himself die 40 minutes in and he starts
to reflect on his past the life he was
forced to lead as a kind of Sideshow
freak more on that later though the
physical Decay happens faster now warts
and moles and other marks of age
appearing on his skin after 50 minutes
he is aware that over half of his life
has passed and he is reaching the end
his hair starts to fall out as do his
teeth which he's never actually been
able to use as he's never tasted food as
the 60-minute mark comes and goes he
begins to feel grateful for the coming
end with the escape from Pain and the
rest it would bring his body has become
very wrinkled by this point and is
covered with age spots his eyes begin to
Cloud severely limiting his ability to
see and his hearing gets weaker and
weaker until he can't comprehend
anything the researchers say at 75
minutes it's all over scp1000 7's body
expires and he dies once again he will
remain as a corpse until the metal key
is inserted into his back and the whole
process starts once again just as there
appears to be no explanation for where
the mass of scp10 0 7's body goes as the
key is wound during the reversal process
so too is there no explanation for where
the energy needed for his rapid growth
comes from this process should violate
the first law of thermodynamics and
Foundation researchers are very curious
about the underline process the one
constant that remains on scp1000 7's
body is a small tattoo on his right calf
where the words Mr life and Mr death
from Little misters by Dr Wonder
tainment appear
this matches up with entry number 11 on
document SCP 909 which lists a total of
20 little misters SCP 10007 was
recovered by task force to 6 during a
raid on a mansion in California along
with several other anomalous creatures
and objects the owner of the Mansion
claimed that he acquired SCP 10007 at an
auction hosted by Marshall Carter and
dark limited Marshall Carter and dark
limited is a club based in London
England that is Fame for collecting and
selling what it would describe as rare
and obscure objects unfortunately this
often includes various anomalies that
should be under the care of the SCP
Foundation and the club's mission to
provide its members with exclusive
expensive and rare experiences means
that they're often in conflict with the
foundation and they have even been
responsible for several containment
breaches Marshall Carter and dark
limited continues to be a very secretive
organization and the name of the
director and a list of its members have
so far been very difficult to obtain at
the auction they hosted where SCP 10007
was offered for sale there were
apparently along with Mr life and death
at least four other misters for sale
though the identity of the other buyers
and which little misters they may have
purchased is still under investigation
the fact that SCP 10007 has the name Mr
life and Mr death seems to imply that he
may have originally been part of a set
though this counterpart little Mister
has yet to be recovered or even
identified in interviews with SCP 10007
he has given his own personal theory
that he embodies both names and the
designation is a reference to the way he
alternates between life and death
however the possibility Still Remains
though that he may have a twin of sorts
and the foundation continues to
investigate its possible identity and
location scp1000 7's brief 75-minute
life followed by a death that lasts
until he is rewound by a special key
means that he is easily contained and
has been classified as safe he is only
to be activated during routine testing
and After experiencing death he is to be
placed back into his coffin along with
the key in keeping with current
regulations for all anomalies that have
been designated as misters SCP 10007 is
to be contained in Hall 8 of site 13 for
additional observation and study scp1 73
it's one of the most iconic anomalies
ever contained by the SCP Foundation
this next snapping site 19 celebrity is
known and feared by everyone who works
at the foundation since being contained
in 1993 its nubby concrete hands
metaphorically and quite literally
stained with the blood of countless
people but this mostly immobile audity
wasn't always a resident of site 19 and
the story of how exactly it ended up
there and more importantly why is far
more ridiculous insane and downright
terrifying than you could ever imagine
so buckle up as SCP fans this is the
dramatic tale of how this homicidal
piece of Modern Art ended up at the SCP
foundation's largest containment site to
give you an idea of just how weird this
origin story is we're going to have to
leap forward to the year of
2045 we know what you're thinking isn't
this a prequel how can it take place in
the future sit tight folks it'll all
make sense in the end s 91 is where we
lay our scene under the watchful eyes of
site director Dr James long a senior
researcher with level four security
clearance the second highest at the
foundation Dr long had given Decades of
devotion and his expertise to the
foundation he was a proud man who wore
his life of service to the containment
cause as a badge of honor after years of
dodging death while researching some of
the most dangerous anomalies that site
91 had to offer he had ascended to the
rank of site director which represented
the culmination of his life's work and
in his new position of power he'd only
proved himself further running a tight
ship and reducing the number of
containment breaches across the board
nobody could say that Dr Long wasn't
extremely talented at his job which is
why he was so confused when he received
an email from Alexandra Nala an
administrative assistant working
directly for the 05 Council it was the
type of email that no site director ever
wanted to receive Dr long was being told
that with no input or oversight from him
the majority of site 91's anomalies were
going to be taken to an undisclosed
location for safer containment the list
contained nearly every meaningful
detainee contained on the site including
of course SCP
173 this particular anomaly had been
contained at the site for 37 years after
being delivered there in 2008 Dr long
had deviced a perfect method to minimize
containment breaches in that time
creating a sprinkler system within the
chamber that watch washes away the waste
products produced by 173 reducing the
need for risky human contact but that
didn't matter despite Dr Long's loyalty
and efficacy in serving the SCP
Foundation the decision had already been
made with no chance of reversing it
according to Nala the motion to remove
most of site 91's anomalies had received
unanimous approval from the 05 Council
and the operations for the transfer
would be commandeered by the department
of extra Universal Affairs headed by
senior agent Sven Kish Dr long was both
upset and confused he was producing some
of the best results across the entire
foundation so why were they taking away
all of his anomalies did someone on the
E5 Council have it out for him Dr Long
replied to Nala asking if considering
how severe the relocation operation was
going to be whether he could get more
information on where the anomalies were
being moved to and why he felt that at
the very least he was owed some answers
on this Nala and her superiors didn't
feel quite the same way she replied that
Dr Long sadly didn't have the clearance
to know any of the operations
particulars this information was
reserved for those with level five
clearance and members of the
multi-universal department all that Dr
Long needed to do was stay out of the
way and everything would be taken care
of for him but that wasn't enough for Dr
long he needed to know more he needed to
understand why this seemingly random
decision had been made realizing that
Nala and the 05 Council were a dead end
as far as information was concerned he
instead reached out to the next best
thing senior agents Fen Kish the member
of the Department of extra Universal
Affairs who was spearheading the
relocation Mission Dr Long implored the
agent to give him extra information on
where all the site 91 anomalies were
being moved and why they were being
moved in the first place predictably he
was once again stonewalled being told
that any information regarding the
project was above his level of clearance
and in a move that seemed decidedly
spiteful agent Kish signed off by saying
that he looked forward to seeing Dr Long
at site 91 and not long after that he
did agent Kish along with a huge number
of agents and task force members from
the multi Department arrived on site
bearing state-of-the-art containment
equipment an exasperated Dr Long wasn't
able to glean any more information from
this experience the multi agents were
ruthlessly efficient transferring The
Lion Share of the anomalies into
temporary containment and transporting
them off site within a few hours by the
time they were done Dr long and his
staff were left with one of the most
desolate and empty containment sites on
the foundation's books here was Dr long
with Decades of service and climbing the
organizational ladder only to be left as
a glorified babysitter for a handful of
low priority anomalous items it all felt
like a cruel joke after several days of
nothing happening in the now incredibly
uneventful site 91 a board Dr Long
reached out to a friend of his
researcher nurul shafik bin Ahmed ibim
whom he called by the nickname Shaq to
vent his frustrations she commiserated
sharing her sympathy for his suddenly
much less exciting working conditions
but saying that at least the job should
be a little less lethal now sha didn't
know it yet but on this particular Point
she was terribly wrong Dr Long shared
his theory that perhaps some sites were
being Consolidated so the foundation
could save money and that this would
lead to layoffs Shaq essentially told
him that he was worrying too much the
reality was that Dr long had some very
good reasons to be worried his problem
was that he hadn't been worrying about
the right things in Foundation
containment area 179 something awful was
brewing as usual guards posted around
SCP 2317 an old door containing a portal
to another world waited while Foundation
staff and DCL classes performed the
standard procedure 220 caliber bass's
ritual within they were dealing with one
of the most dangerous anomalies in the
entire universe but even then after
Decades of service one can be numb to
such things suddenly without warning the
door opened and a terrified Foundation
researcher tumbled out panting heavily
eyes bulging in existential horror he
screamed the words that he long hoped
would never be spoken in his or even his
children's lifetime it happened the
chains have broken the Devourer is free
the siren sounded and an alert spread
across the entire Foundation database
SCP 2317 is compromised SCP
237k the devour of Worlds is free if the
creature escapes area 179 an XK Class
end of the world scenario is basically
assured so all efforts will be taken to
make sure that the creature does not
Escape at any cost and they really did
mean any cost the old wooden door of SCP
2317 splintered has an immense scaly
hands sprang forth and Clau a wave of
Devastation throughout the containment
chamber guards were dispatched in the
hundreds with heavy Weaponry to buy some
time firing at the devour a beast the
size of a mountain Rose from the ground
staring at the terrified humans below
with its one gigantic red eye it
couldn't even feel the bullets
explosives or incendiary and Laser
Weaponry being used on it the monster
just Shrugged it off and murdered nearly
all of its attackers with one swipe of
its claw in a final desperate act hoping
to kill or at least slow down the Beast
staff at area 179 made the ultimate
sacrifice and detonated the entire
onsite nuclear Arsenal the explosion
disintegrated the entire facility in an
instant and Unleashed a radioactive
shock wave that carried Destruction for
miles but it wasn't enough SCP 2317 DK
walked out of the mushroom cloud without
a scratch on it ready to show the human
world what real destruction meant at
this point the battle was already
effectively lost but the foundation
refused to go down without a fight they
dispatched all available mobile task
forces including mobile Task Force new 7
hammerdown a heavily armed Battalion
strength task force created to combat
the biggest and most extensive threats
imaginable and it wasn't even just the
foundation true existential threats have
a way of uniting people has the GOC and
even the chaos Insurgency temporarily
put aside their differences to take the
fight to the Devourer but would any of
it be enough barges of cruise missiles
and icbms did nothing to Halt the
Devourer assault as it Rampage
destroying towns and cities at first
then regions then whole Nations swarms
of scrambled Jets and helicopters were
knocked out of the sky with casual
swipes the creature bulldozed over
Landscapes teaming with tanks and heavy
artillery Vehicles it snapped aircraft
carriers in half as it waited from Ocean
to Ocean systematically destroying
everything in its path
even satellite mounted orbital cannons
and the heavy energy weapons of MTF tow
5 also known as samsara did nothing to
phase the devour it was finally coming
to fruition the dreaded XK Class end of
the world scenario and none of the
foundation's expertise advanced
technology or Limitless resources could
do anything to stop it they aided in
evacuation efforts getting as many
people as they could out of Harm's Way
as the devour rampaged and destroyed but
even that was doing little more than
borrowing time eventually the devour
would destroy all of them there would be
nothing left and all Dr James long could
do was watch helplessly from an almost
empty site 91 waiting for the tide of
Destruction to reach him of course other
Foundation employees most prominently
senior agents ven Kish and the multi
Department had other concerns all they
needed to do was archive data for
extraction extraction to where you ask
seeing as the world seems to be at its
end here well Universe 7392 Epsilon blue
Lima otherwise known as R Universe Circa
1993 the foundation Works across the
Multiverse and an XK Class end of the
world scenario in one Universe really
isn't necessarily a problem in others on
orders of the 05 Council agent Kish and
his men are charged with extracting data
and valuable anomalies like SCP 173 from
doomed universes 05 knew that Dr Long's
Universe Universe 5643 gamma Orange
Delta was due for an apocalyptic visit
from the devour of Worlds any day now
that's why the multi team went in to
extract everything worth Saving Dr long
and the millions of other level four and
Below employees of that universe's
Foundation were never told of their
Impending Doom after all that sort of
thing could probably lead to unnecessary
stress and what they don't know won't
hurt them until of course it does in
1993 these anomalous doomed Universe
scps were divided amongst are universe's
various applicable containment sites SCP
173 as you already know ended up in site
19 but sadly for the people working
there all the actual data files on this
entry's file Were Lost in Translation so
as far as they knew 173 was little more
than a big weird statue with apparently
dangerous properties upon first placing
it in its containment chamber in site 19
uclid Wing Foundation Legend Dr brigh
unaware of just what he had here aign Dr
William Moto to begin research on the
entity he recommended that the
researcher bring 2D classes for testing
when Dr Moto was faced with the
anomalous entity's blank file he gave a
sigh and began to write something in its
description box moved to site 19 1993
origin is as of yet unknown wasn't that
a delightful little tale now we know how
SCP 173 made its way into site 19 and
what our own universe may have to look
forward to in 2045
so remember if you ever see agent Sven
Kish planning a transfer of anomalies
out of your site maybe consider using
some of that PTO and maybe consider
Putting a down payment on a nice cozy
apocalypse bunker over in Iceland know
of other Tales you'd like to see us
cover let us know down in the comments
below it was quiet too quiet that had
been what everyone remembered about that
day ask any member of personnel who was
working what the one thing they recalled
before it happened they'd all tell you
the same that it had been too quiet an
eerie Lull in the foundation's usual
day-to-day activity followed by Untold
unspeakable chaos but the quiet had come
first and within that quiet a Madman was
hiding his name was Vince Barrett at
least that was his legal name but he
much preferred to go by his online
moniker of the tainted lizard or just
the zard for short anyone who chooses to
call themselves something like that in
an attempt to sound cool might well be a
person to avoid and in Vince sorry the
zards case that sentiment was accurate
he was a social recluse devoting a lot
of his time to some of the darker
corners of the internet and we don't
just mean that he spent his days
trolling through Reddit no the zards
interests were in the Paranormal the
unusual and inexplicable as well as the
community of his fellow internet
recluses dedicated to unearthing the
true Supernatural horrors of the world
eventually spending so much time in
corners of the online world where few
normal people would dare To Tread that
would lead to zard becoming a member of
the prolific Forum known as perat this
was the real deal not just urban legends
and blurry photos of Bigfoot or Faked
handheld videos of people falling into
the back rooms parat had long been known
to and kept under the surveillance of
the SCP Foundation why well because this
Infamous online Message Board would
occasionally feature posts about
anomalies some even including scps and
leaked information about the foundation
themselves of course hardly any of these
posts stayed up for very long before the
foundation's tech team scrubbed them
permanently but it was here on the
parwat Forum where Vince Barrett would
encounter a fateful video clip acting
fast he managed to save the file before
it was taken down it was footage taken
from the body cam of a foundation
security officer during the midst of a
containment breach the zard H play his
hand shaking with excitement the
original poster of the clip to parwat
had said that this footage was perhaps
the only known video on the entire
internet that depicted something known
as SCP 682 the hardto destroy reptile of
course those familiar with 682 and the
SCP Foundation will need no introduction
but Vince on the other hand had only
never heard rumors about this creature
and now in the video playing on his
computer screen he was seeing it for the
first time the reptile was free from its
containment chamber tearing its way
through a foundation facility and making
quick work of dispatching the security
Personnel that dared to stand in its way
it was a force of unbridled Carnage and
rage destroying anything in its path and
adapting to its environment deep in the
parat Forum the zard had read rumors and
leaks from alleged X Foundation staff
and detractors that 682 was like
something out of a nightmare they said
that the creature could adapt perfectly
in response to damage inflicted upon it
or to changes in its environment as well
as heal any injury it sustained it
persisted it kept on going and something
about that enamored Vince to the
infamous anomaly he thought it was
beautiful the ultimate apex predator and
admired the hard to destroy reptiles
tenacity as well as as its ferocity
watching the horrific Containment Breach
footage he realized then and there that
he was a devoted fanatic of SCP 682 his
time on the dark side of the web had
twisted his mind and led him to make one
fateful decision that he needed to see
the creature in person that had been
almost a year earlier and in the time
since the tainted lizard had pulled on
every dark web string he knew of
eventually getting in contact with a
shady group called the chaos and urgency
Vince had managed to get a hold of a
real life SCP Foundation key card as
well as the location of the facility
they were holding 682 in and a forged
transfer document posing as a humble
unassuming janitor theard had made his
way inside the foundation and wasted no
time in making a beline straight for the
acid tank where 682 was held he stared
at the creature through the glass eyes
wide and Jaws slacked in utter awe of
the Monstrous reptile perhaps the
biggest fan of of SCP 682 on the planet
couldn't quite believe he was standing
in the presence of the creature itself
it barely seemed to pay him any mind
from the other side of the tank the acid
surrounding it melting 682 as fast as it
could heal seeing it in containment
enraged Vince he hated that the
foundation had kept what he viewed as a
perfect organism locked up after having
tried time and time again to destroy it
don't worry the zard murmured
approaching the tank well over the
minimum safe distance you're Force of
unparalleled destruction and you don't
deserve to be here I'm going to set you
free unfortunately after the glass had
been smashed and the alarm screamed out
that another Containment Breach was
occurring Vince would quickly find out
that the reptilian Beast he revered so
highly didn't quite hold him in the same
regard if you thought the zard was going
to make it all the way through the story
alive well then we regret to inform you
that you're sorely mistaken although not
as wul misguided as Vince himself who
was the first person in the path of SCP
682 when he freed the creature but all
those leaks and rumors on pawat had
failed to mention about the heart to
destroy reptile was its vehement and
Relentless hatred for all other forms of
life including its very own fan and the
tainted lizard was only the first
casualty of SCP 682s latest Rampage but
this time was different sure 682 was
easily tearing its way through SCP
Foundation Personnel left and right
security teams were flung aside and
ripped to Treads as they tried in vain
to recontain the Monster research staff
found themselves tripping over each
other trying to rush out of the
destructive path of the hardto destroy
reptile only to find themselves the next
to face its ferocious attack in other
words it seemed to mostly be another
unbridled Slaughter common fair for an
SCP 682 Containment Breach except rather
than Breaking its way out of the
facility this particular instance saw
the creature heading in the direction of
another anomaly SCP 914 better known as
the Clockworks now if a rampaging
regenerative reptile on the loose wasn't
enough cause for concern then seeing it
moving along its trajectory to another
anomalous refinement machine certainly
was those that had been on the other
side of the facility when the dearly
departed zard set 6 city2 free were now
looking on in horror as the hard to
destroy reptile burst into the room
housing SCP 914 the foundation staff in
the midst of panic stared at security
monitors with baited breath palpable
fear hanging in the air each and every
one of them knew that SCP 682 was more
than just a Mindless Beast the creature
was fiercely frighteningly intelligent
sentient even and as it approached the
controls for the Clockworks every
onlooker secretly hoped something or
someone would step in at the last second
and prevent SCP 682 from entering the
machine unfortunately that's not not
what happened SCP 914 word into life its
gears and Gyro spinning as SCP 682
entered the input booth now normally the
way the Clockworks operates is by
destroying any item placed within it and
replacing it with something else in the
output Booth depending on its setting it
either completely disintegrates an item
breaks down an object into its base
components replaces it with an
equivalent or improves it and being set
to very fine as it was right now SCP 914
can even add anomalous properties to
whatever is put inside of it but what
happens when an indestructible and
infinitely adaptable monstrosity is in
the Clockworks Well it can't destroy and
recreate a better version of something
that would be known for being hard to
destroy can it the entire machine was
going haywire SCP 682 was adapting to
the refinement process refusing to let
SCP 914 unmake it even to replace it
with an improved version of its itself
the hardto destroy reptile and the
Clockworks were at a momentary stalemate
and watched with baited Breath by the
foundation as CP 914 began to
malfunction its Clockwork components
getting stuck as if the machine was
jammed its cogs were clogged up unable
to destroy the subject in the input
Booth the room around was beginning to
Shake in fact the very ground was
trembling at the force of the whole
machine shuttering enact the abandon all
hope protocol the head of research said
desperately watching the events unfold
from the other side of the building the
site director looked at them and nodded
the pair of them entering their secure
passcodes to activate this secretive
security measure just as they did a
small earthquake erupted underfoot the
entire wing of the facility housing the
Clockworks and SCP 682 had collapsed
into the ground a huge crater was all
that remained littered with wreckage of
a whole portion of the foundation site
along with broken pieces of SCP 914 for
the next few minutes minutes everyone
was on edge secretly hoping that SCP 682
hadn't survived maybe the Clockworks had
managed to destroy it but the sheer
force of doing so had caused the machine
to collapse in on itself or perhaps the
hard to destroy reptile was now buried
beneath several thousand tons of debris
dead at long last but the foundation
staff knew better than to get their
hopes up and sure enough just as an
armed security team approached the
crater something started stirring in the
rubble sudden ly SCP 682 came bursting
out of the crater emerging in not quite
the same state although no less deadly
than before the Clockworks hadn't been
able to unmake the hard to destroy
reptile but the resultant malfunction
and explosion had imbued the creature
with a whole host of new anomalous
abilities it still resembled its old
self but was now more humanoid standing
by pedal instead of on all fours some of
its body mass had seemingly been reduced
due to damage sustained in the
malfunction although SCP 682 was still
plenty of feet taller than an ordinary
human being in fact it could be any
height it needed to be the creature's
scaly skin seemed to be shifting
unnaturally moving of its own accord
like it was already preparing to adapt
to oncoming damage and as the nearby
security team were about to find out
this made it even deadlier than before
in a panic the foundation officers
opened fire only to find that their
weapons weren't operating the way they
should something caused excitation of
the copper shells of their bullets
making them either expand and block the
barrels of their guns or causing them to
backfire horribly injuring the security
Personnel wielding them before anybody
could even call an air support or heavy
artillery as a backup a number of the
foundation's most powerful weapons
suffered even more catastrophic misfires
missiles detonated early they hadn't
even been aimed at SCP 682 yet but they
would have been instead they exploded
taking with them a huge huge number of
foundation entities some miles away from
where the newly refined reptile now
stood SCP 682s regenerative Powers had
been altered by the Clockworks it wasn't
purely reactive to oncoming damage now
it was preemptive it could adapt to
attacks that hadn't even happened yet
with no way of stopping it SCP 682 began
decimating everything in its path with
greater ferocity than ever over the
coming days the newly dubbed impossible
to destroy
began its biggest Rampage yet entering a
permanent rage State and unleashing
destruction on a global scale it stormed
through cities and wiped out entire
major population centers in moments it
seemed nothing on Earth could stand
against the refined reptile fueled by
its singular mission to wipe out all
life in existence the surviving
Personnel of the SCP Foundation soon
came to learn that no damage could be
inflicted on the creature whatsoever SCP
682 could predict ICT attacks ahead of
the person that would carry it out and
then adapt changing the very world
around it so that attack never came the
impossible to destroy reptiles
adaptations usually took the form of
diverting any oncoming damage it
preempted it would take and instead
inflicted that same damage on whoever it
chose even though the machine had
malfunctioned the Clockworks had made
SCP 682 that good at adapting to its
surroundings that the creature had
almost become a universal constant the
fact that it could not be harmed now
seemed to be as fundamental of a law as
that of gravity but that wasn't going to
stop the SCP Foundation from trying the
number of casualties the world over had
been increasing steadily day by day as
SCP 682 continued its devastating
campaign of Slaughter some of the
remaining scraps of the foundation had
tried to subdue the creature but any
attempts at fighting it with
Conventional Weapons were ill advised to
say the least after all how do you fight
against a creature that can predict your
every move and counter them before
you've even thought of those moves well
you can try throwing something so
unexpected at it at least pulling
something out of left field means that
the chances of SCP 682 seeing it coming
are slightly Slimmer and that was where
the abandoned all hope protocol came in
you see the foundation had been
anticipating that 682 Would One Day
become too powerful to contain long
before the creature had gained its new
ability to preemptively adapt and while
the worldwide death toll had climbed
from hundreds of thousands of innocent
people to the earliest Millions an
unlikely Counterattack was brewing one
so unexpected that even the impossible
to destroy reptile would struggle to see
it coming just as Humanity was facing
the brink of Extinction the foundation
dispatched their last hope at stopping
SCP 682 other scps the abandoned all
hope protocol had been devised for when
the suffering and destruction caused by
SCP 682 became so great that there were
no other options left when it had been
activated Foundation agents stationed at
various sites across the world had
gathered a specially selected group of
anomalies each one was chosen because
they were known to be sympathetic
towards Humanity or at least be coerced
into taking on SCP 682 and now these
scps were stepping up to the plate ready
to fight the impossible to destroy
reptile or more likely to die trying SCP
076-2 The Immortal Warrior known as Abel
was Infamous for picking fights the
ancient Sumerian swordsman had a pension
for seeking out the most challenging
adversaries so convincing him to take a
crack at SCP 682 wasn't all that
difficult however rushing into battle
against the refined reptile Abel quickly
found he couldn't draw his weapons from
his pocket Dimension they were
dissipating the moment his fingers
touched them Vanishing faster than he
could draw no matter the warrior thought
he'd been alive for centuries and thus
had become a master in every form of
hand-to-hand combat as you can imagine
he didn't last very long left to slowly
revive inside his Stone tomb after SCP
682 had finished dispatching him Abel's
brother Cain incurred a slightly
different result when he went toe-to-toe
with the impossible to destroy reptile
SCP 073 was hardly the fighter his
brother was but had the anomalous trait
of deflecting incoming damage back at
whoever was inflicting it on him so when
SCP 682 attacked Kane theoretically the
same attack would have bounced back and
harmed the reptile itself and before
that's what would have happened but now
SCP 682 could adapt preemptively a
strange neverbe seen phenomenon occurred
it appeared that neither SCP 073 nor the
refined reptile were harming each other
at all however on a metaphysical level
the potential damage of 68 2's attacks
against cane were being reflected back
towards the reptile only for the
creature to preemptively adapt to the
damage from its own attack being
inflicted back what resulted was a
feedback loop of Perpetual possible
damage that ended only when Cain
eventually passed out from shock
unfortunately while he could reflect
damage back at an attacker he felt the
pain of every hit and as CP 682 had more
than just a mean right hook the
foundation had hoped given its 100%
mortal record that scp096 would have no
trouble killing the impossible to
destroy reptile or at the very least
harming it enough so that it could be
subdued after all 682 still needed to
see and anyone looking at the shy guy
quickly met their end but when the tall
pale humanoid approached SCP 682
something unusual happened the reptile
could look at scp096 able to see it
perfectly perhaps the creature's
adaptive properties were creating an an
intentional blind spot in its Vision
removing scp096 from view or maybe 682
no longer saw with just eyes perceiving
the world in a manner far beyond our
understanding of basic sight but
whatever the case the impossible to
destroy reptile made scp096 turn and
flee in Terror compelled to put an end
to the reptile's reign of terror SCP
4494 the Spectre manifested nearby and
tried to intervene the result was
nothing short of brutal a one-sided
fight that not even the living
embodiment of crime fighting could hope
to win after SCP 682 had finished off
the Spectre a strange black fluid began
oozing from nearby although one of the
hardest to Wrangle the foundation
believed that they had convinced SCP 106
to Aid in taking down SCP 682 the old
man emerged from the oily secretion
shuffling menacingly towards the
impossible to destroy reptile it seemed
to treeze as if it was taking a
defensive stance against the old man
either that or tricking him into getting
closer before he could even reach out a
decrepit hand to touch the reptile
shifting skin SCP 106 was suddenly
coated in copious amounts of the black
substance he secreted it coated him like
thick tar the more his decaying body
produced the more he was covered in it
normally he was resistant to the
corrosive burning effects of this
substance however SCP 68 2's preemptive
adaptation Powers had caused scp-106 to
overproduce the oily substance enough to
rapidly dissolve the old man into a
steaming black puddle it was at this
point that SCP 343 colloquially known as
God lowered his newspaper and looked out
of his window that is to say he looked
out of the huge hole that had been left
in the wall of his cell being omniscient
as CP 343 was already burdened with the
awareness of what had happened SC SCP
682 had been defined into an even worse
version of itself by the Clockworks up
until now God had been happy to avoid
all the fighting and just see how
everything worked out but as much as he
tried to distract himself SCP 682
slaughtering other scps and droves was
getting in the way of his reading oh
this again in a split second the entire
universe had been unmade and then remade
Almost exactly the same except SCP 343
had made a slight adjustment giving a
little nudge to cause and effect in a
few places as a result a certain
misguided Forum user had never and would
never infiltrate the foundation and
break SCP 682 free leading to the
hard-to destroy reptile being refined by
the Clockworks although while it had
been unceremoniously returned to its
original form and placed back in its
acid tank SCP 682 could still remember
the power it had wielded only moments
before everything had been Rewritten all
it needed was another chance to get into
the Clockworks scp096 the shy guy woke
up in an unfamiliar room without a
thought in its head however one thing
quickly occurred to it this was not its
containment chamber no the solid steel
Cube that had kept it locked up for
decades now didn't have a front desk or
walls covered in strange childlike
murals or tiny party music playing over
old speakers wherever scp096 had found
itself it certainly wasn't the place it
had come to call home if it could read
it would have registered the words
behind the front desk painted onto the
wall ban Ban's kindergarten where Joy
Comes Alive little did 096 know
something really did come to life here
at band band's kindergarten but it
definitely wasn't Joy scp096 was
typically used to a much more confined
space so so presented with so much
strange Freedom its natural instinct was
to wander around whimpering quietly to
itself this place was certainly peculiar
with multiple large reinforced doors
each one having a large red button fixed
to the wall above them a strange green
creature was painted on the wall with an
a fixed speech bubble that read jumbo
Josh says eat fruits and vegetables if
you want to be strong like me though 096
paid no mind to such things this place
looked like an SCP Foundation
containment facility mixed with an
off-brand chuckecheese and some tiny
part of the shy guys's dim and dismal
brain wanted to see more of it what
other Secrets could it hold the shy guy
pressed one of the big red buttons
causing the doors to open underneath it
there was a faint sound of childish
laughter somewhere down the distant Hall
how had it ever found its way into such
a strange place the deeper the shy guy
wandered the more strange murals it saw
saw on the wall there was one for a
large orange cartoon jellyfish with one
staring eye where the speech bubble read
Stinger Flynn says having many arms
allows me to help a lot of people then a
squat blue gorilla likee creature with
sharp lower teeth had a speech bubble
that read Captain fiddles says UGA Booga
boaa a white feminine catlike creature
had the speech bubble bambolina says
kindness is free so sprinkle it
everywhere a misshapen pink bird
creature had the speech bubble Opa bird
says laughter is the best medicine so
make sure to smile and of course most
importantly of all presiding over the
creativity room was a mural of a
grinning red creature wearing a pair of
party hats on its head like horns his
speech bubble read ban ban says sharing
is caring your pancreas is mine a
whiteboard not far from this mural had
the words run for your life hastily
scrawled onto it to anyone but the shy
guy who had no point of reference this
was clearly not a normal kindergarten as
the shy guy passed into the hallway
slowly lumbering along it suddenly felt
an intense Spike of burning pain right
through its forehead Rising like a fever
pitch the shyu subdued whimpers quickly
escalated into horrifying whales of
animalistic rage this could only mean
one thing somewhere something had made
the Terrible mistake of gazing at the
shy guy's face in fact not 10 ft away
the unfortunate opala bird had made that
very mistake it typically peaked out
from behind one of the hallways pillars
to get a good look at any potential
Intruders or new prey wandering into its
midst but this time the beastly Bird's
curiosity had taken it from Predator to
prey itself though it wouldn't realized
this until it was already too late as
the mutant bird creature scattered back
into the cavernous Hall filled with
plastic trees and an underwhelming play
area the shy guy came Galloping after it
on all fours roaring with Fury the opela
bird was shocked to see the creature
giving chase this doesn't make sense I
meant to chase you you're not meant to
chase me but things are rarely fair when
it comes to the shy guy arguably one of
the most dangerous uclid class creatures
ever kept in Foundation containment the
opala bird flapped desperately towards
the boarded up escape hatch but the shy
guy was so much faster he grabbed hold
of the bird gripping it in its iron
clutches and began to stretch open its
bottom jaw with a blood curdling Roar
we'll spare you the details of what
happened next but suffice to say little
more than a handful of feathers were
left after finishing off the opala bird
the shy guy reverted from Rage back to
pitiful sadness this place was no better
than the SCP Foundation there were still
creatures here to look at its face and
drive it into a state of extreme
emotional distress it was horrible the
shy guy needed to find a way to hide
himself away again so he decided to tear
away the planks covering up the escape
hatch and L down the narrow Hall and
there the shy guy actually found
something to its liking two platforms
one on either side of the room with what
seemed to be a deep dark Chasm between
the two for most there was an electrical
lift system for carrying them between
the platforms but the shy guy had no
interest in the platforms he only sought
the darkness below where nobody could
see his face that would suit him just
fine the shy guy jumped over the
guardrail and plummeted down below into
the dark feeling the air against its
cold gray skin as it fell felt wonderful
it dared to think that it might even
find solace in this deep dark place but
as soon as he hid something solid some
kind of metal lift system alarms went
off and flashing red lights soon made
everything down there in the darkness
visible to be exposed like this while it
thought it was hidden was the dreaded
Shy Guy's worst nightmare little did he
know he would soon become the worst
nightmare of a number of other beasts as
the shy guy crawled off the metal
platform hoping that perhaps it could
find another place to hide down here its
hands and feet splashed into shallow
water had something sprung a leak down
here the shy guy began wandering the
half dark as the water of this flooded
sub basement area pulled around him it
had no idea that another creature was
already sneaking up behind it getting
ready to strike before 096 could even
react several whip-like orange tentacles
wrapped around its Limbs and began
delivering an antagonizing shock through
its body more tentacles came in soon
after wrapping around the Shy Guy's body
and face delivering shock After Shock
After Shock with its millions of tiny
venomous Stinger barbs for a second it
seemed like the surprise attack might
actually be able to subdue the monster
but little did the shy guys attacker the
Monstrous real Stinger Flynn know that
attacking it was just another way to
activate its Infamous rage State the
second that Stinger Flynn relented even
just for a moment the shy guy grabbed
him by the tentacles and slammed him
into the watery floor again and again
and again until the grip of his
tentacles loosened around the Shy Guy's
body and he was defenseless with stinger
panicked and immobilized the shy guy
released the full force of his
Supernatural Fury striking the Demonic
jellyfish with his fists until what was
left couldn't be distinguished from the
water it used to be floating in Stinger
Flynn had been completely annihilated
the shyy once again temporarily returned
to a state of calm and wandered out of
this watery basement into a nearby
hallway where everything was bright and
dry the walls were painted in garish
childlike drawings of a jungle with
janky look looking animals the shy guy
paid no mind to any of it all he wanted
was to find somewhere that he could
actually be alone and a away from prying
eyes of all these freaks this dream was
shortlived because as soon as the shy
guy found a new room a wide open
Auditorium filled with inflatable jungle
trees like a crude play area he was
being stalked yet again a powerful
muscular Predator with veins stretching
over its bulging muscles and blue skin
it knew that this Intruder had already
killed two of its fellow Garden dwellers
but this time it would put the spindly
pale Stranger in its place the shy guy
heard something rumbling towards it from
behind and turned upon hearing the blood
curdling war cry of ugaa boa UGA it was
the gorilla like Captain fiddles with
strands of saliva hanging from his tusks
he leaped onto the Shy Guy and began
pounding into its hideous face with his
huge blue fists Captain fiddles would
destroy the shy guy pound him into the
concrete until he stopped moving the one
thing that Captain fiddles didn't expect
was for the shy guy to start fighting
back and he was about to learn the hard
truth that the shy guy could fight a lot
harder than him the scp's spindly but
immensely powerful arms grabbed Captain
fiddles by the shoulders and threw him
into the wall causing huge cracks to
crawl up towards the ceiling before
Captain fiddles could even think about
wrenching himself free the shy guy
leaped to his feet and bounded over to
him the shy guy grabbed Captain fiddles
by the ankles and ripped him out of the
wall letting his body drop to the floor
and then unleashing hell upon Him
Captain fiddles would have begged for
mercy if he wasn't already dead before
the shy guy could even begin to calm
down a trap door opened in the floor
beneath him dropping him into a new area
a multicolored maze where 096 was
trapped like a helpless rat with the
body count of an atomic bomb once again
the shy guy didn't need to go looking
for for trouble because trouble was
already on its way the Pure White
catlike B bolina pounced from a sharp
corner in the Maze claws Beed she jumped
onto the shy guy latching onto him
inclin trying to scratch his nightmare
of a face if the shy guy had ever
possessed anything resembling patience
he would have run out long before now he
grabbed bambolina shrugging off the pain
of her claws and tossing her into the
darkness high above she flew off with a
catlike yell and hit distant ceiling
with a crunch suffice to say she
wouldn't be back to bother the shy guy
again tired and angry the pale
Abomination didn't feel like wandering
through a maze instead it just charged
straight through destroying colorful
wall after colorful wall when it
encountered whatever was behind this
extremely frustrating afternoon it would
destroy it with extreme prejudice that
was almost certainty after breaking
through one more wall the shy guy
tumbled out into a strange room where a
grinning red creature was waiting for
him wearing two party hats on top of his
head this was no mere Lackey it was ban
ban himself the one behind this
nightmarish kindergarten he stared right
into the shy guy's face with no fear at
all almost like he knew something that
the shy guy didn't and it was true he
had no plan to fight the shy guy himself
he'd brought a champion with him as the
shy guy started to scream and rage all
the boxes behind ban ban tumbled out out
of the way as a huge figure Rose a
behemoth at least 50 ft tall with green
skin giant teeth and huge staring eyes
it was jumbo Josh and if the shy guy
wanted to graduate from this nightmare
kindergarten it would need to defeat him
and ban ban the shy guy growled digging
its claws into the ground and preparing
to charge forward challenge accepted Dr
Bradshaw had only been working at the SC
foundation for a few years but in that
time he had seen things that had changed
him irreparably ancient texts about
world-ending Abominations machines that
could spontaneously produce any food or
drink from nowhere friendly slime
monsters with a pension for tickling
invisible kleptomaniac women and wannabe
heroic men covered in spikes but one
anomaly in particular stuck with him
haunted his dreams and dominated his
waking thoughts as CP
049 that mysterious Mass doctor with his
deadly touch and stranged Beak Visage
trying in vain to cure something he
would only refer to as qu the pestilence
and quote the great dying his cure was
more like a curse it seemed as his
unusual treatments transformed his
patients into the Mindless Living Dead
shuffling around as malform shells of
their former selves if this was The Cure
Dr Bradshaw found himself often
wondering what was the disease many
researchers had attempted to get to the
bottom of this question over the years
interviewing SCP 049 and nurturing their
own pet theories in their free time but
none had ever received a satisfying
answer ever reached a real conclusion it
was this Legacy of fruitless
hypothesizing and questioning that led
Dr Bradshaw to pitch his own plan for
unmasking the pestilence once and for
all he would gather every prominent
Theory his colleagues could come up with
including several of his own then he
would simply engage the plague doctor in
polite discourse walking him through
each Theory one by one and waiting to
see if any of them Stu it took Dr
Bradshaw weeks to collect and distill
the theories down into a workable list
of questions consolidating those that
overlapped and eliminating those that
were simply ridiculous such as Dr Brit's
potentially factious insistence that the
pestilence was lactose intolerance but
when the day came he felt ready to take
on the task when the interview was
through perhaps he would have managed to
do what none before him at the
foundation had perhaps he would
understand what the plague doctor was
fighting with his unorthodox methods and
by extension how they could pacify him
non-lethally once and for all Dr
Bradshaw held his notebook tight as he
made the long walk down the hall from
his office to SCP 049 Containment
chamber this was it the Moment of Truth
he hoped he had asked his colleagues to
pump the scent of lavender into 04 9's
room to put him at ease as well as give
him his dinner just in time for the
meeting he hoped that the meal a little
glass of wine and the peaceful
atmosphere would make the plague doctor
more amable to his line of questioning
SCP 049 was sitting in front of the wide
glass window fork and knife in hand when
Dr Bradshaw arrived hello doct Bradshaw
gave 049 away I ah good evening they
told me I would be having company for
dinner but where's your food sir oh I'm
I'm not hungry Dr Bradshaw brushed him
off politely nosense it would be
horribly rude for me to eat while you
have nothing excuse me he called to a
guard nearby please bring this man a
helping of what you've served me so we
may dine together with a sigh Dr
Bradshaw nodded at the guard giving him
permission to do what the plague doctor
asked a few moments later he too had a
trade with a plate of fish and roasted
vegetables and a small cup of wine on
the side now may I ask you some
questions the plague doctor nodded
indeed what is it that I can do for you
I was hoping you could teach me more
about the pestilence Dr Bradshaw began
delicately the plague doctor perked up
have you come to assist me with my work
my dear fellow why did you not say so
from the start it would be my honor to
provide you with all the knowledge I
possess on this subject if you intend to
to lend the hand I just want to
understand more about it first Dr Brad
Chaw said it wasn't quite a lie not
really he did want to understand he
flipped open his notebook scanning the
page for the first of the positive
theories he had gathered is it possible
that what you refer to the pestilence
you're talking about pain as a whole the
plague doctor cocked his head to the
side what do you mean well you once
described scp096 as being Afflicted with
an extreme case of the pestilence I
believe and when you cure someone
they're no longer able to feel any pain
physical or emotional I know that you
mean well but is it possible that's what
you're trying to treat the pain that
naturally afflicts all human life most
living things the plague doctor scoffed
you think that I a physician am so
ignorant of pain that I would
misdiagnose Agony as a something so
devastating as secr dying if you are
here to insult me sir I will simply ask
that you leave I'm sorry that was not my
intention please let me stay I promise
I'm only here to try and understand will
you withhold judgment until I'm finished
one man of science to another the plague
doctor paused moing this over he nodded
I will heal your questions and do my
best to answer them thank you Dr
Bradshaw smiled and returned to his
notes so you have been in the field of
medicine for quite some time and I
imagine you've studied a variety of
Sciences you work with a lot of liquids
and substances none of us have ever
encountered before were they the result
of alchemy used to balance the humors of
your patience I was curious if your
treatments and if the pestilence itself
is theurgical in nature that is to say
well magical the plague doctor let out a
sharp laugh at this
magic sir I am no magician nor am I an
alchemist as I have never forly studied
Alchemy in any form the humors of course
must be balanced for proper for health
but that has nothing to do with Alchemy
in my opinion how is your black vile you
appear to have an excess of it do you
experience a great deal of stomach pain
Dr Bradshaw rushed to steer the topic
away from him and his health lest the
plague doctor offer to treat him not
particularly next question his eyes
returned to his notes let's see we've
noticed that you seem to cure those who
are most afraid of death and dying and
when you first arrived at our facility
you stated that there was less
pestilence here than other places you
had been most of our staff have seen
enough death and Misfortune that it no
longer frightens us we inoculated
against it essentially one researcher
working with you was afraid of death at
first but as he came to accept it as an
inevitability you said that he was no
longer infected is the pestilence fear
itself or more specifically the fear of
death the plague doctor mold this over
one's Outlook one's attitude can impact
their health it is easier to fight a
disease when one does not let fear take
over but other than that I'm afraid I do
not understand your question the
pestilence is simply what it is why are
you more preoccupied with categorizing
it than curing it I believe that to
understand something is to know how to
fight it Dr Bradshaw answered
simply we may differ there but you may
continue I'm grateful for the company
and for your desire to understand
misguided though it may be thank you
doctor I wanted to ask you are you
familiar with the Scarlet King the
plague doctor's expression did not
change I have seen the rise and fall of
many monarchs in my time why would you
ask me about this Scarlet King that
wasn't a no well Dr Bradshaw began
according to Legend one of his many
daughters was pestilence a bringer of
disease and destruction is she the one
you intend to fight I know not every
single forms the pestilence takes only
the grip it has on this world SCP 049
answered for your sake I would advise
you to avoid speaking of such matters
that King he is not the thing you wish
to face Dr Bradshaw jotted down a quick
note in the margin of the page Scarlet
King connection possible then he
returned to his line of questioning have
you spoken with SCP 343 I have the
plague doctor nodded and what did he
tell you it is not worth going into here
according to him the pestilence that you
were refer to is Humanity's free will
you were changed by something a long
time ago a tragedy that turned you
towards your work you came from a dark
place one of the places even 343 can't
see is that true I will not answer that
question it is an insult as CP 049 said
again not a no exactly but still Dr
Bradshaw did not want to push too hard
too soon and risk the doctor terminating
their conversation my apologies I'll
shift to something different
you once treated the Bubonic plague
correct SCP 049 shook his head no I am
not familiar with that particular
condition Dr Bradshaw had prepared for
this he pulled a medical illustration
from his notebook depicting a victim of
the black plague uh what about something
like this SCP 049 side ah now this
element I have encountered before I did
my best to treat it but it was stubbor
is it related to the pestilence
Dr Bradshaw asked not necessarily 049
said nothing more than that he took a
sip of wine ate a bite of potato he
wasn't going to offer any more insight
into that particular Theory it seemed I
mean no offense with this next question
but doctor have you always lived here on
this planet or did you make your way
here from another world of some kind
perhaps the pestilence came from
wherever you did see well this change
held me a great deal in my life life SC
CP 049 said but I have always been here
at least as best as I can recall he
seemed to be telling the truth but with
that unmoving inscrutable expression it
was difficult to be sure this next
Theory would be extremely difficult to
float without offending 049 but Dr
Bradshaw had to try he needed to do his
due diligence are you familiar with the
story of Typhoid Mary he would ease into
the idea that would probably be best I
am not SCP 049 sounded puzzled she was
an asymptomatic carrier of typhoid Dr
Bradshaw explained as others grew sick
around her she remained healthy and well
she had no idea that as she worked as a
cook in the houses of wealthy families
she was infecting them with a deadly
disease it was not any moral failing of
her own she didn't understand what she
was doing but she still spread the virus
throughout her community stop right
there the plague doctor's tone was Stern
tense I know what you you are suggesting
and it offends me to my core if you do
not see C file implications I will be
forced to end our talk here and now I am
a physician sir I do not endanger my
patient so recklessly I understand
better to leave that theory alone for
now you said that you have always been
here but I do have to ask have you ever
heard of a place called alagada there
are those that claim you once lived
there that you came from that Kingdom I
have never heard that name that I can
recall but I have lived a long life
perhaps I have forgotten what nation
does that belong to Dr Bradshaw paused
it was his turn to be stumped I'm not
sure do you know who the black Lord is
he couldn't be certain but he thought he
saw SCP 049 frown villain a villain he
grumbled under his breath I banish him
from my thoughts that he may never again
enter my sight his gloved hands clenched
into fists and Dr Bradshaw jotted down
another note in the margins the black
Lord he had devoted plenty of time to
everyone else's theories it was time for
one that he had been earnestly
considering doctor it is my opinion that
the pestilence may be connected to
emotional state or heart rate perhaps
both when you treat your patients do you
remove the heart or the amydala to
address those issues I've noticed heart
removal during a handful of your
procedures you have a Kai SCP 049
enthused however I do not always remove
the heart it varies greatly from Patient
to Patient you see for some the heart is
a crucial part of the infection for
others it impacts the brain others steal
the liver or the larger nervous system
that is why it is so difficult to treat
you see it can manifest in seemingly
infinite ways but what about emotions
negative impulses cruelty selfishness
hatred is that a component I was
reviewing your file and you mentioned an
excess of the pest pence in the home of
a wealthy man known for exploiting his
workers and mistreating his family when
you were cross tested with SCP 682 you
remarked that the pestilence did not
only impact humans suggesting the
anomaly was also infected and you cured
your patients well they don't seem to
have a hateful impulse in their
bodies hate can be a disease the plague
doctor took another bite of food chewing
slowly when he swallowed Dr Bradshaw
expected him to elaborate on this
thought but he didn't so Dr Bradshaw
broke the silence the Four Horsemen of
the Apocalypse the ones that bring about
the end of the world war famine death
and pestilence there have been stories
about them for thousands of years do you
know pestilence personally are you
protecting us from him from the end of
days SCP 049 scoffed I work in science
not stories I intend no disrespect to
your beliefs but surely you hear how
absurd that sounds pestilence does not
ride in on a horse it resides in the
body you've lost patients before haven't
you every physician has if what they are
treating is severe it never gets any
easier to do so I'm sure have you ever
lost someone special to you though done
something you truly regret perhaps the
pestilence was a manifestation of some
guilt or trauma some shame he could
never truly let go every man has regrets
do you not have those secret shames
doctor Dr Bradshaw changed the subject I
have always wondered this can you see
the misdeeds that someone has done can
you somehow sense the sins of their past
all the harm they have caused why do you
ask SCP 049 cocked his head again are
you afraid I can see something within
you he couldn't explain why but the
question made his stomach turn no he
answered it was a lie will everyone
catch the pestilence eventually as time
goes on the odds do become greater yes
but not everyone is doomed is is that it
is it time the passage of time aging
Decay The Great dying you called it so
is it dying itself your cured patients
they don't age they never Decay any more
than they already have death is not
natural SCP 049 simply said all things
die eventually Dr Bradshaw argued I have
not died yet SCP 049 took a drink of
wine well there was no arguing with that
something else I've been thinking about
is the possib ility that the pestilence
is greater than just one thing Dr
Bradshaw began his next Theory doctors
believed at one time that the plague was
caused by an imbalance of the humors in
the body they could recognize the
presence of disease but couldn't
routinely tell them all apart several
different illnesses were referred to as
consumption and leprosy was used as a
catchall for multiple illnesses as well
clearly you have a knack for knowing
when someone is ill but what if it's
something else something equally bad but
different from what you think it's
cancer or a stroke or a heart condition
there is no one cure except for the
massive transformational work you're
already doing possible SCP 049 mused I
will need to consider that point
carefully perhaps you have unlock a
secret to the pestilence I missed and
again perhaps not if the pestilence is
not death and I do have to wonder is it
the opposite life is a temporary state
for so many of us less lucky than you
and it seems like you cure your patients
of natural life when you treat them they
become something not quite dead but not
quite living at least not as they were
and illness ailments hurt all comes as a
natural side effect of being alive so is
the great dying life itself I do not
understand the question and thus I will
not respond to it SCP 049 stated Dr
Bradshaw could sense that the plague
doctor was growing frustrated getting
tired of so many questions that poked at
his beliefs his research and his process
is the pestilence natural or something
man-made humans have created diseases
before cause them to mutate or worsen
them with chemicals we invent have you
heard of Agent Orange I don't mean to
digress but my point is it's not unheard
of for people to be responsible for a
disease I wonder is the pestilence
something that developed on its own or
is it are doing a biological weapon a
synthesized virus or artificial mutation
created by other scientists or maybe Dr
Bradshaw paused here referring once more
to his notes is it sin greed lust wrath
Pride Envy gluttony sloth maybe not that
biblical that exact but is it evil the
sort of thing that rots away at a human
soul not a plague of the body but of the
very essence and the only way to cure it
is to rip the whole thing out and start
over you seem to have the answers in
mind before you ask me these questions
doctor I will allow you one more before
I take my leave I have found this whole
ordal quite exhausting Dr branon nodded
okay just one more is it something
unnatural not man-made not of nature
viruses or bacteria but something else
altogether Something From Another
Dimension another world or the spaces in
between youve been Cy about the nature
of the pestilence for as long as you
have been here and I understand if you
are just being cautious but I can't help
but wonder if there is something else to
the reason you keep so much to yourself
you promise to tell me about the
pestilence but you've barely responded
to most of my questions except to
dismiss my ideas is the pestilence
something that spreads by thought that
lives in the Consciousness or the
subconscious of us all waiting dormant
for something to activate it and set the
sickness free the plague doctor sat down
his fork with a clatter I respect your
scientific curiosity but there are
things I cannot share with you for my
safety for yours for everyone's do take
care doctor you too Dr Bradshaw stood
from his chair collecting his notes and
preparing to leave one final thing Dr
Brad shot turned back to face the plague
doctor yes those dark eyes watched him
from inside the mask do you see any of
the pestilence in me the silence that
passed between them felt like an
eternity then SCP 049 spoke no sir I do
not but one day that could change as Dr
Brad made his way back to his office the
words echoed in his mind and he couldn't
make up his mind whether they were
comforting or troubling he had gone into
the meeting with questions but now he
had even more than he started with ever
since she was in high school Faith had
dreamed of moving out and finally
getting a place of her own it wasn't
that she didn't love her parents she did
but they were always around always
coming into her room without knocking
telling her when to go to bed when to
wake up not to eat dinner in front of
the TV in college she had some welcome
Independence but she had to live with
roommates again they were perfectly nice
people some of them she even considered
good friends but she hated having to
share her space having to come home from
a long day of classes and see someone
else's dishes piled up in the sink to
have someone else's music keeping her
awake at night to delay her morning
shower because someone else had gotten
there first so she was thrilled when a
few years after graduating she got a new
job at a marketing company that would
finally let her afford a place by
herself at last she could have some
peace some quiet and most importantly
some privacy Faith spent all day moving
furniture and unpacking boxes turning
the little apartment into a real home it
wasn't much just a main room she used as
a bedroom and living room a bathroom and
a basic little kitchen but it was all
hers and all of the little personal
touches she'd put together really made
it feel like the place was meant for her
there was the orange couch she'd picked
up at a vintage store downtown the
coffee table she'd gotten for free from
her last roommate bring pictures of her
family and friends a bed with Linens in
her favorite color light blue and lots
and lots of potted plants over time she
would find even more things more little
personal touches to liven up the space
now how to celebrate her new home her
gas wasn't on yet so she couldn't cook
anything but that was the perfect excuse
to order in 30 minutes or less later she
was kicking back on her couch with a
large cheese pizza watching a scarying
movie on her TV no one would ask to
switch it over to the bachelor no one
would take the last slice while she was
in the bathroom it was perfect finally A
Little Piece of Heaven an introverts
Paradise as she finished her first meal
in the new place she felt her eyes
beginning to grow heavy the day of
strenuous unpacking catching up with her
body just as she was thinking about
calling it a night a pale-faced monster
appeared out of nowhere on screen
terrifying the movie's main character
and making Faith jump spilling her soda
all over the coffee table damn it she
groaned already she'd made a mess but
hey she tried to look on the bright side
it was yet another first to break in the
apartment she grabbed a kitchen towel to
mop up the soda and when she returned to
the main room she froze
there was something in the window
standing out against the darkness
outside at first she thought it was a
reflection a trick of the light but as
she slowly approached the window eyes
wide and hands trembling she got a
better look there was a face a little
difficult to make out as if it were
peering Out of the Shadows but
unmistakable nonetheless it was pale
human vaguely resembling a strange man
with dark circles under his eyes and and
he was looking right at her she didn't
scream she was too terrified to make a
sound she stared at the face for a long
moment waiting for it to do something
anything after several moments of the
tensest staring contest of her life she
blinked the face didn't budge you you
need to leave she finally spoke
surprising herself as she did if you
don't get out of here I'm calling the
cops again the face stood nothing do you
hear me her voice climbed in Pitch her
heart pounding against the inside of her
chest who was he what did he want she
became vaguely aware of the fact that
she couldn't see the rest of the man's
body just his face looking at her with a
neutral expression a look of vague
curiosity like someone watching a caged
animal at the zoo might have it was then
she remembered something that made her
blood run cold made the towel drop from
her hands as her stomach sank she lived
on the third floor her apartment had no
balcony no fire escape he could have
climbed up whatever was looking at her
through her window it was no ordinary
peeping Tom she couldn't say how long
she stared at the face its unblinking
eyes its inscrutable expression she
moved closer to the window step by step
until she was almost nose to nose with
the thing she couldn't think of it as a
person though it looked like one mostly
she should run screaming out the door
looking for some kind of help but what
would she say that there was a floating
face looking at her through the window
what if it was somehow all in her head
some sort of hallucination brought on by
exhaustion and the stress of the move
she raised a fist and following a
passive Instinct wrapped on the glass
she didn't know what she expected for it
to Blink to move to knock back to say
something but nothing happened it just
stayed there as if it were part of the
window itself Faith pulled the curtains
closed hiding the strange face from view
with any luck it would be gone on in the
morning she had worked hard to get this
apartment and she would be damned if she
let some strange thing whatever it was
drive her out of her new home but as she
climbed into bed and pulled the covers
up to her chin she could still feel its
Gaze on her as if it could see through
the thick fabric of the curtains she
rolled over onto her side her back to
the window and tried her best to forget
about it to shake that horrible feeling
of being observed she lay there for
hours Eyes Open Heart r racing but
finally the exhaustion won and she
Slipped Away into sleep she didn't dream
at all that night it was as if she
closed her eyes and seconds later it was
morning she woke to the beep of her
alarm feeling as if she hadn't rested at
all the first thing she did was climb
out of the bed and go to the window
carefully tentatively she opened the
curtains she let out a sigh of deep
relief the face was gone she must have
imagined it after all a bit concerning
but as long as it didn't happen again
she wouldn't have anything to worry
about lack of sleep does strange things
to the mind after all no longer plagued
by the fear of that strange face faith
hopped into the shower and let the
worries of the previous night wash away
disappearing down the drain she brushed
her teeth dried her hair did her makeup
and dressed for work after a banana and
a quick cup of coffee she was out the
door work was exceptionally busy that
day and it pushed any memory of the
Oddity in the window out of her mind
entirely she was even feeling good
enough to accept her friend's offer to
grab a drink after work they met up at a
bar down the street from her new place
sharing cocktails memories and a plate
of onion rings it was a perfect lovely
evening by the time she got home
savoring the click of the key in the
lock as she let herself into her quiet
little Sanctuary she had completely
forgotten about the unusual Apparition
she swung the door open and rushed to
dump herself onto the couch for a bit of
TV before bed then out of the the corner
of her eye she saw it the face back in
its previous Place staring at her from
the darkness outside she gasped at the
sight her scream catching in her throat
it was just as she remembered it wait no
something was different what was it she
clapped her mouth in horror as she
identified the change its expression was
different gone was the vaguely
interested neutral expression now it was
smiling at her not a pleasant smile not
a warm friendly smile a wicked smile
twisted and cruel it knew she was afraid
that she'd been hoping it was gone
forever and it was enjoying itself her
hands were shaking nervous sweat beating
on her brow what do you want from me she
whispered staring into its eyes they
didn't move but they glittered with
malicious Glee just the same what do you
want from me she repeated her voice
rising to a shout shut up her next door
neighbor yelled banging on the wall it's
it's after midnight she couldn't bring
herself to respond she had more
important things to attend to her
stomach turned bile rising in her throat
with the face begun again in the morning
would it come back again at night was
the apartment haunted possessed by a
spectre doomed to reside in her window
forever was that why the rent had been
so affordable or maybe it was her maybe
this thing had been drawn to her or
maybe she was losing her mind
unaccustomed to living alone and her s
was slipping away she shivered at the
thought what was worse if the face was
all in her head or if it wasn't rather
than attempt to answer the question
gnawing at her she closed the curtains
out of sight out of mind she thought she
would have to keep the curtain closed
possibly forever it was better than
seeing that damned face grinning that
horrible grin but as she tried to settle
in for another restless night she could
feel its eyes boring into her burning
into her skull she had never felt felt
so uneasy before she prepared for
cockroaches for black mold and for
burglar but not for this this was
something outside of her understanding
outside of reality itself just don't
look she whispered to herself just don't
look at it it became part of her daily
routine wake up ignore the window go to
work try to forget about the window get
home tried desperately not to think
about the window she could always feel
it though as soon as the sun went down
though she kept the curtains closed she
knew it was there she thought about
checking to see what face it was making
this time but she couldn't bring herself
to look gradually her condition worsened
she woke up to a tightness in her chest
panic attacks that wrecked her body and
felt like her heart might stop beating
her stomach would ache she struggled to
keep food down one morning she rushed to
the bathroom and spat up blood the
effect began to follow her out of the
apartment too far away from the fa's
dwelling she she would sit at her desk
struggling to focus on marketing
campaigns and pitches and she would feel
a sudden pain in her stomach forcing her
to double over and groan with Agony she
would see flickers of the pale face in
her peripheral vision turning to look
only to find there was nothing there
when she walked down the hall to the
elevator or down the street outside her
building she would feel as if someone
was following her she never saw anyone
never heard any footsteps coming up
behind her but she could never shake off
the sensation soon soon even her
formerly dreamless nights of sleep as
fitful as they had been became unsafe
she would toss and turn sweating through
her sheets as her subconscious was
tormented by chilling visions and
terrible nightmares she would dream of
walking down a long dark hallway that
seemed to go on forever and something
coming up behind her trying to grab her
and drag her away it would chase her
wide dark eyes and long long limbs
grasping at her as she ran and ran but
never escaped other times she would
dream of being locked in a damp basement
chained to a wall as the pale creature
sat in a chair across from her just
watching waiting for something though
she didn't know what every night another
nightmare that made her wake up
screaming fighting off invisible
attackers after 2 weeks of living in
hell she decided to look out the window
again she had to see had to know that
night when she opened the curtains it
was there mouth wide open eyes glinting
it was laughing at her screw the deposit
enough was enough she wanted her home
back she picked up the heavy lamp on her
bedside table wound it up and threw it
out the window with all her might the
glass shattered little crystalline Shard
sprang in every direction as the lamp
flew through the air out the window and
down to the street below and just like
that the face was gone she checked every
other window in place the little one in
the bathroom the people on her door but
it was nowhere to be found she was free
her knees gave out and she collapsed to
the floor her face in her hands and wept
from sheer relief tomorrow she would
clean up the broken glass and spin her
landlord a story about a freak accident
someone would come to fix the window and
it would be the best money she had ever
spent eventually the whole ordeal would
fade away from memory like a bad dream
but somewhere out there someone else was
living the nightmare all over again
looking out to darken window to see an
unwelcome Guest The Entity known as SCP
scp-965 is a phenomenon affecting framed
windows when it appears it manifests in
the shape of a shadowy face belonging to
a pale man staring in through the window
the details of the man's face vary from
person to person as well as his apparent
age and the direction he is facing
however all reports point to the same
figure at various ages ranging from 10
to 55 the foundation has attempted to
use facial recognition software to
identify a citizen matching the
description of this figure but so far no
one has been found SCP 965 will not
appear in just any window it will only
manifest when the lighting on the
outside of the window drops below
illumination of five candalas the
lighting on the inside of the window
does not have any measurable effect the
face will only appear in the confines of
a completely assembled window frame
though the window does not necessarily
need to be installed anywhere it will
only move from one glass pane to another
if its original point of manifestation
is to destroyed the face can be seen
from an outside vantage point though it
has been described by observers as
looking away into the room when
scp-965 first appears to someone it
produces feelings of unease anxiety and
lowgrade paranoia anyone within the
visual range of the affected window will
experience these feelings even if the
window is covered by curtains or any
other means any individual that sleeps
in an area visible to SCP 965 is
manifestation point will begin to
experience difficulty sleeping suffering
from upsetting and disturbing dreams
however this is not the end point of the
entity's impact on those it appears to
at a point between 3 and 10 nights of
sleep after its initial appearance the
entity's facial expression will begin to
shift into a noticeable smile after the
shift the victim symptoms will become
physical as well as mental including
ulcers and intestinal bleeding heartburn
abdominal pain and even vomiting blood
this has been attributed to the entities
influence on the human body's reaction
to heightened levels of stress and fear
the subjects that reached this stage of
exposure to scp-965 begin to see its
face in Windows in their dreams as well
as spotting it in their peripheral
vision while going about their Waking
Life they begin to see the face out of
the corner of their eye even when the
affected window is nowhere in sight
these additional sightings are
accompanied by lingering feelings of
paranoia and The Sensation that
something is following or watching them
though the entity has never made a sound
and does not move while it is visible it
can disappear and reappear in different
poses it has also displayed notable
signs of sentience appearing
disappointed when it manifests in an
empty room and angry if it sees someone
who broke its previous window when
presented with one of the agents who
first brought it into custody The Entity
appeared frightened for the first time
testing involving SC SCP 965 involving
the destruction of its host window
confirmed that a multi- pained window
might act as multiple holding zones but
significant damage to its overall
structure keeps it from being a viable
replacement in this particular case the
entity manifested in a nearby
experimentation chamber observation
window which was promptly destroyed in
order to prevent any potential breaches
for a month following this incident The
Entity manifested with noticeably
hostile facial expressions clearly
resentful of its treatment only one
other notable incident has occurred so
far during during the course of SCP 965
containment by the SCP Foundation Dr L
the rest of her name has been redacted
from the official file was the head
researcher assigned to SCP 965 for
several months before she filed an
official request for transfer to a
different test subject she was beginning
to experience intrusive visions of
scp-965 and lingering feelings of
paranoia lasting long after she left the
foundation site her symptoms were
consistent with those of someone who had
slept in the presence of the entity
though she swore up and down she had
never napped or slept at all in the
vicinity of the affected window she was
temporarily relieved of her duties and
provided with psychological care so far
no other instances of SCP 965 impacting
staff who have not slept in its presence
have been reported but this case set an
unsettling precedent the mental health
of anyone assigned to SCP 965 is to be
strictly monitored in case it expands
its influence again SCP 965 is contained
within a framed ready to install window
made up of six panes of clear glass or
other comparable material at a size of
at least 15 cm x 30 cm the window must
be kept in an environmentally controlled
storage facility capable of withstanding
earthquakes and other seismic activity
the window must be inspected at least
once a week in order to check the
Integrity of the material additionally
at least two identical framed windows
must be stored in the same facility in
separate Chambers with additional
insulation any Lighting in the
containment chamber should be kept at a
minimum of 130 kandelas at any time
Personnel are inside with the exception
of research and experimentation though
SCP 965 is currently contained the
foundation is unable to control its
movement should its current window be
destroyed therefore SCP 965 is
classified as uid scopophobia is the
fear of being watched or looked at by
others those suffering from this fear
will often avoid Windows terrified of
who might be standing on the other side
staring in and keeping track of
everything they do even those of us
without scopophobia might find ourselves
feeling a prickle of dread while looking
out the window at night watching for a
shadowy figure or a ghastly face pressed
to the glass most of the time of course
there is no one there it's just an
overactive imagination the lingering
effect of watching one too many scary
movies but eventually your luck might
just run out one night when the world
Falls quiet and you go to close the
curtains before you go to sleep just in
case you might just feel that someone is
right there on the other side of that
thin pane of glass staring at you with
wide unblinking eyes it won't ever come
inside but it isn't going anywhere and
as long as you are where it can see you
you will never know peace again growing
up in a small Virginia Town near the
mountains right on the border of of West
Virginia Zayn heard all kinds of stories
from his grandmother Tales of mountain
lions who could transform into ghostly
women The Tao a fluffy rodent like
creature on an endless quest to get its
tail back from the hunter who took it
the moth man that appeared with glowing
red eyes to warn of impending tragedy
most of all she warned him about the
deer sometimes she used to say when
you're out in the woods late at night
you'll see a deer acting a little bit
funny maybe it's making strange sounds
maybe it's standing up like a man maybe
it's staring at you from the shadows and
won't look away if you ever see one of
these deer promise me you'll get away
from it as fast as possible don't look
at it don't talk to it just get far far
away he promised her every time but as
he got older he started to forget his
grandma's stories letting them fade away
with memories of the Easter Bunny and
Santa Claus he didn't think about the
stories again until he was older a
junior in college and embarking on a
camping trip with his roommate Josh they
were both staying with Zayn's family for
the summer and had been enjoying the
sunshine and fresh air they'd gone
hiking picked blackberries and gone
fishing to their heart's content after a
while they got sick of sleeping in the
cramped house and decided to have a
proper camping trip out in the mountains
campsites were crowded this time of year
but Zayn knew a spot just isolated
enough that they could kick back enjoy
nature and relax in piece they packed
their supplies and headed out into the
forest for a weekend they would never
forget by Nightfall Zayn and Josh had
pitched their tents built a fire and
were starting to make some dinner they
roasted hot dogs and heated cans of
beans over the fire and decided to start
telling some classic scary stories
sitting by the crackling fire listening
to the rustling leaves snapping twigs
and the chittering of animals all around
Zayn couldn't help but remember the
stories he had almost forgotten all of
the strange inexplicable things that
came out after the sun went down and the
forest went quiet he thought he could
hear the footsteps of something walking
by their campsite circling them but it
was probably just his imagination as
Josh told stories about babysitters
stalked by Killers and drivers picking
up ghostly hitchhikers Zayn was thinking
about the deer he shuddered but shook it
off and after some more stories and a
few too many s'mores the two friends
decided to get some sleep after several
hours Zayn woke to the sound of Josh
unzipping his tent he sat up ready to
yell at his friend for waking him up but
the sight of Josh's pale frightened face
stopped him there's something here was
all Josh could say his hands Zayn
noticed were shaking hey man it's it's
okay let's check it out Zayn patted Josh
on the shoulder he was pretty sure his
friend just wasn't used to camping in
actual nature but reached for his
hunting knife just in case he grabbed a
flashlight and switched it on following
John out into the darkness he swept the
beam across the clearing and it
illuminated a pair of orange eyes
staring directly at him from behind a
nearby tree what the he approached the
shape trying to get a clear look at it
as it became more illuminated his
stomach dropped it was a deer but
something was wrong with it its mouth
was wide open its jaw working up and
down like it was trying to make a sound
but nothing came out but that wasn't the
worst part as the flashlight beam
illuminated the animal's body Zayn
realized that somehow its head was on
backwards what Josh appeared behind him
gasping sh Zay shushed him intensely he
suddenly remembered his grandmother's
warnings you know what I don't feel so
great I think we should go back to the
car and head to my place he gave Josh a
look shaking his head as if to say don't
say another word by the glow of their
flashlights the two packed up their
campsite all under the Gaze of the
misshapen deer they drove home in
silence Josh only speaking once to ask
what was that thing Zayn shook his head
I don't know but it wasn't a deer they
crept back into the house and went to
bed they knew they would never speak of
tonight ever again as Zayn began to
Drift Off to Sleep his last conscious
thought was to glance out the window
there in the yard not 5 ft away was a
deer watching he didn't know it but that
night Zayn encountered an instance of
SCP 6
448 SCP 6448 is an anomalous species of
creatures that appear to belong to the C
family nicknamed the not deer they are
highly intelligent and can be
distinguished from ordinary deer by
unusual behavior and physical
deformities some of these have included
legs that bend backwards the eyes of an
animal other than deer forward- facing
eyes jerking movements lack of fear
towards humans and walking on two hind
legs eggs most notably and most
frightening SCP 6448 instances will
watch and stalk humans for a duration of
hours or even days they will follow
humans home and steal items from their
domains including weapons food and other
personal items they're most frequently
found in the Deep Woods at night when a
person is completely alone if someone
encounters an instance of SCP
6448 if they acknowledge any of the
creatures anomalous traits it will
attack in order to limmit the loss of
life and ensure that the SCP Foundation
employees exercise the utmost caution
when dealing with SCP
6448 the crypto zoology division issued
the following guidelines if you notice a
deer that seems off look away and ignore
it if it knows that you've noticed it
it's too late if you hear your name
whistling or something else in the woods
calling for you don't acknowledge it
never acknowledge it exists exists don't
respond don't go looking for it don't
call back to it if you're walking at
night and you feel something breathing
on your neck or Whispering behind you
the key to your safety is pretending
that everything is normal your survival
is dependent on your ignorance whatever
SCP 6448 is they appear to be
intelligent enough to understand when
they are being studied and they don't
seem to like it very much on January
11th 1994 a group of three SCP 6448
instances broke into site 41 in North
Carolina using a tunnel they had carved
over a long period of time at the time
there was an instance in containment but
in all of the chaos of the breach the
specimen was lost every time an instance
was captured and contained near SCP 6448
habitat it would later Escape via
similar tunnels SCP 6448 was officially
classified by the SCP Foundation in 1980
but those from the Appalachian region
have known about these strange creatures
since at least
1947 from folktales and campfire stories
to secondhand and even firsthand
encounters the locals are aware of the
not deer's existence and are largely
familiar with the precautions necessary
to avoid them though many of the
civilians that encounter SCP 6448 avoid
notifying the authorities there have
been several recorded 911 calls
involving the n deer since 2000 the
following is a log of those calls
February 1st 2000 victim age 41 female
dialed Emergency Services after hearing
their name being called from the woods
near their home the victim recounts the
vocalization being likened to a scream
in a voice that they do not recognize
and requested assistance in locating the
source emergency Personnel requested the
subject placed their phone on the floor
outside the home to listen for the
alleged sounds after two 2 minutes a
vocalization was heard that was calling
to the subject by name emanating from
the nearby Forest the subject was
instructed to investigate the
disturbance themselves and keep Services
updated on the situation the victim then
began to walk into the Woodland getting
about 50 m into the underbrush before
inexplicably stopping they claim there
to be a noticeably large deer standing
in the way of the path she begins to
walk closer though States it does not
move subject diverts from the path and
begins walking in a different direction
after 30 minutes no source of the voice
is determined the caller returns to
their residence June 13th 2002 victim
age 28 male calls 911 regarding a home
break-in the caller notes numerous items
to be missing from their residents and
requests an investigation operators
dispatch two investigators to visit the
home and and pertain a potential
perpetrator the pair note that based on
earlier CCTV images all Cutlery sharp
objects Firearms light bulbs and a
single copy of the novel The Day After
Roswell are missing also noted is that
there is a complete lack of any
fingerprints at the scene with no doors
or Windows having been broken into an
Alis of the H CCTV footage revealed
there to be a 2-hour period of missing
film with the exception of a single
frame containing a service nippen on its
hind legs reaching towards the camera
its frontal Hooves have been warped to
resemble fingers no footage of the
entity exiting the home was discovered
November 19th 2005 a cattle farmer age
54 male reported to local authorities
the sudden disappearance of over 30% of
his largest herd Response Team searched
the nearby area for 4 hours though found
no trace of his cattle the victim was
recommended to set up trail cameras and
note any unusual activity overnight at
1:11 a.m. two scps 6448 are seen walking
through the field before fleeing one
places an object into the ground later
discovered to be a single Fork a week
after this discovery 200 discarded
bovine Hooves appear at the location
March 4th 2009 victim age unknown gender
unknown dials 911 to request assistance
from Animal Services the victim is
standing within a forest in front of a
service elice which is violently
contorting the victim attempts to State
you better get a vet or something I
don't think it's well before a piercing
Screech is heard and the line Falls
silent recovered footage depicts the
aforementioned animal squirming
seemingly in pain a vicious churning is
audible as a black mass erupts out of
the instance and the video turns to
static October 11th 2012 victim age 23
male is a junior Wildlife officer at the
Cherokee National Forest Tennessee they
radio their supervisor in the early
morning regarding a herd of AIC colus
virginius within the reserve
supposedly there is a single animal that
upon first glance appears average though
possesses Divergent attributes including
backwards joints enlarged abdomen and
forward-facing Eyes Upon stating this a
distant whistle is Audible and the
victim stumbl slightly they begin to say
what the did it just whistle at me
before the sound of hooves rapidly
getting closer is heard notably the hoof
steps did not sound to be in the
traditional Gallop of a servid October
12th 20 2 the former victim supervisor
calls authorities following the victim's
absence from The Reserve Night Shift
following this their radio begins to
crackle the victim's voice can be heard
on the other end and he requests the
supervisor's attention he calls
regarding a herd of autolus virginius
within the reserve they claim there is a
single animal that upon first glance
appears average though possesses
Divergent attributes including backwards
joints enlarged abdomen and
forward-facing eyes suspecting the
creature to be a rare genetic
malformation the victim requests their
supervisor to come to the location the
supervisor questions the victim about
what happened the night previous there
is no reply upon the supervisors and law
enforcement's arrival at the site a herd
of approximately 80 Odus virginius was
present a single entity is in the field
Center and appears to be standing
separate from the rest of the group it
fleas the scene upon realizing the law
enforcement's presence where it formly
stood lay a standard two-way radio April
8th 2016 victim age 35 female dials 911
using a satellite phone distressed they
State they are in reducted County woods
and are being followed she claims that
despite seeing no one for the duration
of her hike she quote feels as if she's
being watched and has heard someone
walking behind her at various points in
the trip the victim is unable to give an
adequate description of their location
but knows the route to return to her
residence operators request the victim
to return to a point wherein she can
provide a sufficient Geographic
description of her position the victim
remains on the line for the duration of
the hike back to a readily used portion
of the Wilderness Trail along the
journey various unnatural sounds can be
heard these include footsteps Rock
slides coughing whispering and whistling
nearing the main trail all Woodland
noises such as birds and winds cease
suddenly and the victim State she can
see a malformed deer carcass coated in a
thick layer of black slime at this time
human screams can be heard in the
distance operators request the victim
continue and ignore the other stimuli
agents embedded in local law enforcement
suspecting SCP 6448 involved notify
gamma 4 to the situation 20 minutes
later the victim returns to the main
trail gamma 4 now operating the 911 call
informs the victim not to respond to any
further unusual activity and brly outlin
service protocol for the duration of the
victim's journey to her home two sets of
breathing are audible the victim
successfully returns to her residence
and shuts the door behind her now out of
sight from SCP 6448 agents inquire of
the victim's address and the victim
promptly complies operatives instruct
the victim to have possession of all
firearms and weapons on the premises and
to barricade herself inside a safe space
with one exit point the victim swiftly
begins grabbing all available weapons
and throwing them inside a wardrobe it
is at this time there's a n knock on the
front door the victim does not respond
and continues to hoard sharp objects
from kitchen drawers the knocking
becomes more violent as the handle is
jostled and is shaken incessantly a
voice on the other side repeats the
phrase hello it is me hello let me in in
a calm manner as the door begins to
shake the victim retreats to her
wardrobe armed with a small firearm upon
sealing herself in the space the
knocking ceases and footsteps can be
heard becoming further away the sound of
Galloping is audible as the front door
caves in hoofsteps can now be heard
inside the home The Entity continues to
repeat hello it is me hello let me in as
it searches the small building a bright
light flashes overhead seemingly
circling the house eventually The Entity
enters the victim's bedroom through a
small slit in the wardrobe door the
victim can see a service canadensis
standing on its hind legs and surveying
the room its movements are crooked and
stiff seeming to struggle to stand in a
bipedal fashion it slouches down to a
quadrapedal Crouch similar to The Stance
of an arachnid it inhales heavily and
its head locks on the view of the
Wardrobe it is noted as possessing human
eyes it scampers towards the subject and
opens the door a single gunshot is heard
responders found no trace of either SCP
6448 or the victim containment of SCP
6448 is focused on the investigation of
any deer exhibiting anomalous traits in
and around the Appalachian area any
civilian sightings of SCP 6448 are to be
handled by mobile task force gamma 4 or
the green Stags any possible deaths
resulting from SCP 6448 will be blamed
on hiking accidents and any reported
sightings can be explained away with
chronic wasting disease CWD occasionally
referred to as zombie deer disease is a
Pyon disease affecting members of the C
family symptoms of the illness include
loss of motor function control and
damage to decision-making as well as
gradual degradation of all mental
faculties it is 100% fatal however
though the disease does exist most
recorded cases of it in the Appalachian
region can actually be attributed to
instances of SCP
6448 any captured instances of SCP 6448
should be transported to site 44 for the
crypto zoology division's containment
and study on November 29th 2019 they
finally got their chance to bring a not
deer into custody the green Stags were
able to capture an instance of SCP 6448
with a help from MTF new7 hammer down
and their heavy Vehicles Division as
well as some experimental shock rifles
one not deer was knocked unconscious in
the conflict and its body was loaded
onto an armored helicopter and flown
straight to site 44 in Essex England at
the side it was then placed in a
reinforced steel containment cell and
heavily sedated this entire process went
off without a hitch as the entity began
to regain Consciousness crypto zoology
specialist F Oz watched it through a
one-way glass window and attempted to
speak to it through the intercom
greetings SCP
6448 researcher Oz began at the sound of
his voice the creature jumped to its
feet staring at the intercom can you
understand me we've seen your genus
speak English just fine in the past the
animal did not answer but began licking
one of its legs and behaving as if it
were an ordinary deer researcher Oz
sighed impatiently please we know your
secret the KN deer stopped what it was
doing freezing completely still as it
listened to the words admittedly it
wasn't exactly well kept if you just
look at yourself for more than a few
seconds it is very clear that you're not
normal at this the creature which had
been facing away from the window
swiveled its neck
180° breaking its own spot with an
audible crack it stared unblinking at
the window and directly at researcher Oz
Oz turned to the containment staff
suddenly anxious I thought you said this
was one way the staff assured him that
it was and there was no way the not deer
could see him still its eyes were locked
directly on his face he shook off the
sense of unease and continued his line
of questioning are you something
imitating dear it is clear that if so
you possess basic anatomical knowledge
of them though de details are clearly
faulty in fact a better question would
be how if in fact you are not what you
pretend to be the not deer opened its
mouth at this revealing unusually sharp
teeth it moved its jaw as if attempting
to speak but only a choking sound came
out sh shall we move on Oz asked what
I'm more concerned with here is why you
take our people is it a vendetta spite
food for the first time in the interview
the not deer blinked it was an unnatural
movement forced and deliberate like the
creature was attempting to engage in an
ordinary Behavior rather than actually
experiencing an involuntary impulse
responding is mandatory researcher Oz
prompted the creature did not react if
you will not comply Ma's tone grew Stern
frustrated maybe you'd like to see your
brand new containment cell at last The
Entity
spoke reearch
its voice resembled a distorted version
of Oz's research what kind of Oz wasn't
able to finish his question July 7th
1947 the creature said before ramming
into the one weight glass and cracking
it as Oz stumbled backwards from the
force the creature collapsed on the
ground seizing and screaming as its
abdomen get the Stags in here now Oz
cried out but it was too late a black
mass of something shiny and tender
leaped out of the not deer scuttling
around the cell before shattering the
window and leaving the empty shell of a
deer behind the site 44 breach system
activated and attempted to initiate
emergency containment protocols but the
mysterious black mass escaped its sector
made its way toward the main exit broke
through the glass of the front exit door
and vanished into the Shrubbery outside
the escaped anomaly could not be found
and recontained ever since this incident
there have been a record-breaking number
of chronic wasting disease cases
identified in deer in the surrounding
area as well as an unprecedented
increase in UFO reports further research
is currently ongoing but it is unknown
whether we will ever truly know what
these creatures are only one thing is
for certain they are definitely not dear
when you work for the SCP Foundation you
need to be ready for anything that's why
as part of the elite foundation training
regimen senior research and guards are
always running tests even against things
that aren't recorded anomalies under the
opes of the foundation that's why today
for a real change of pace here at SCP
explained we're not talking about the
SCP Foundation we're talking about
madeup monster stories crowdsourced over
the Internet we're seeing how the
foundation might Faire against iconic
Creepy Pasta monsters and Maniacs like
Herobrine Jeff the Killer the Slenderman
isas Jack smile dog and many many more
we've even created all new mobile task
forces to take each one down so could
any of them best the foundation's best
and brightest let's take a look and find
out and be sure to tell us which is your
favorite Creepy Pasta entity down in the
comments below let's get creepy Jeff the
Killer first up we've got everyone's
favorite disfigured knife wielding
homicidal teenager whether it's his
terrifying Visage or the iconic go to
sleep catchphrase that's forever carved
into your mind there are probably a lot
of people out there who have lost nights
of sleep worrying that this pale-faced
monster could be crawling through their
window but we know what you're probably
wondering isn't Jeff just a serial
killer why would the SCP Foundation use
up its time chasing down any old regular
human murderer we'd ask for you to think
again Jeff has displayed Feats that
clearly Mark him as anomalous despite
suffering debilitating Burns to his face
and body he still shows superhuman
strength agility and durability he's
also able to see without eyelids
suggesting some Supernatural element is
at play victims have also reported him
dodging shotgun blasts while stalking
prey so how would the foundation catch
him seeing as Jeff's modus operandi is
breaking into the homes of his victims
while they sleep the best method would
be staking out a neighborhood where he's
been shown to be active keeping close
observations on houses and even setting
up Personnel from mobile task force
Sigma 9 my name of Jeff in vacant houses
as honey traps Jeff is undeniably strong
fast and tough but if attacked and
surrounded by operatives with Superior
Tactics he could be subdued without
casualties then it would just be a
matter of transferring him to a standard
high security humanoid containment cell
speaking of horrifying creatures that
come to you in the dead of night The
Rake this Supernatural entity has been
around for almost a thousand years as
far as scattered reports are aware it's
also been reported across four
continents and a huge number of
locations within those continents though
most recently it's been reported in
rural New York State and Idaho in the
early 2000s The Rake is an inhuman Beast
most often known for its large
frightening eyes and its long rake like
claws not only does the monster feed on
human beings but it also produces a
traumatic level of fear in its victims
thankfully an entity like this is far
more familiar territory for the SCP
Foundation using their state-of-the-art
web crawler software they could catalog
reported sightings as they happen and
use clusters of these sightings to
triangulate the location of the rake and
dispatch field agents to perform
reconnaissance missions from there it
would just be a matter of of waiting to
strike and sending in Mobile task force
Zeta 13 rake steppers fitted with Dr
Dan's scramble goggles to prevent them
from being affected by the seemingly
Cognito hazardous effects of viewing the
rake when the creature is placed in
containment and kept in a state of
Perpetual bright light it would simply
be a matter of applying a Scranton
reality anchor to prevent the creature
from somehow phasing out of containment
just make sure you avoid its big staring
eyes in the meantime time though that
won't be a problem with the next Creepy
Pasta monster eyess Jack this stealthy
creature has its no eyes on one thing
and one thing only your kidneys and
unless you want to die or spend the rest
of your life on a dialysis machine we
recommend you keep your distance from
him he's discreet Dev and diabolical and
if you wake up in the middle of the
night to see him staring down at you it
may be the last time your body is able
to filter toxins out of its blood
naturally thankfully we have a way to
make the foundation put a stop to his
organ harvesting ways sometimes to catch
a jack you need to use a jack there's no
way to catch isas Jack without delicious
live kidney bait so we'd recommend
sending in someone who has kidneys to
spare Dr Jack brigh brigh could be the
perfect bait without losing his life
luring idolist Jack into a decoy house
while mobile task force G G 391 Hit the
Road Jack prepares to Spring their
cunning trap and plunge this unpleasant
kidney muncher into a humanoid
containment cell forever but our next
Creepy Pasta entity doesn't want your
kidneys it wants your life Smile Dog our
next entity seems like a harmless little
JPEG to the untrained eye a little
freaky sure but nothing to lose your
mind over but we know that there's far
more to this grinning husky than meets
the eye if some reports are to be
believed this image may even be
connected to the Devil Himself if you're
unlucky enough to see this image in the
world it may already be too late for you
those who see it typically as an email
attachment from a mysterious address
spend the last week of their life in a
hell of the Mind before eventually
succumbing to oblique and mysterious
death it's a classic Cognito hazardous
image and the most frightening part is
that it's self-propagating
with one of the only ways to even mildly
alleviate the effects seeming to be
spreading the word by subjecting another
person to this nightmare that's when we
bring in Mobile task force row 19
Naughty Dog an elite group of hardened
military programmers handpicked from the
cia's cyber warfare unit they use their
very particular set of skills to design
WebCrawler software that Roots out and
takes down Smile Dog images across the
web and hopefully one day find the
origin of this whole thing the next
creature on the other hand we've given
up on finding the origin of that the
expressionless this entity kind of looks
like a terrifying store window mannequin
except rather than modeling fast fashion
she prefers to swallow cat's hole and
murder Hospital staff oh and she also
calls herself God isn't she just so
quirky her primary abilities seem to be
extreme strength and large sharp teeth
that will easily Ren through through
human flesh thankfully not anything the
SCP Foundation hasn't dealt with
countless times before seeing as the
only recorded incident involving the
expression list took place at a hospital
in Los Angeles that would be the most
sensible area to stake out a detail from
the creature's original encounter is
also telling it reacted severely to the
doctor's attempts to sedate it implying
that chemical sedation is an effective
method of incapacitating the beast
that's why every member of mobile task
force Kappa 99 ain't no dummy is a
sharpshooter with a tranquilizer rifle
capable of putting a hippo to sleep with
a single shot she'll probably feel less
like a god in her containment cell but
while this monster is expressionless the
next one has one very notable expression
Mr Widemouth compared to some of our
other Creepy Pasta contenders Mr
Widemouth may not look like much but
that our dear friends is exactly what
this Nast little malactor wants you to
think he may look like Gizmo's slightly
demented cousin but his intentions are
even more Sinister than that of your
average Gremlin if you're a kid home on
a sick day Mr Widemouth might strike up
a conversation after gaining your trust
he'll try to lure you to his special
place beyond the trees for some fun but
take it from us all you'll find out
there is your doom this crafty little
creep small stature and manipulative
stealth is abilities might pose somewhat
of a challenge for the SCP Foundation
but that doesn't mean they can't get him
with a little intelligence and elbow
grease mobile task force Alpha 18 the
smile Smashers will follow reports of
children disappearing from their
isolated homes under mysterious
circumstances then using an extra
strength butterfly net straight from the
folks at Foundation R and D they can
chase down and capture the nasty little
monster but that won't be the case for
this next demonic offering no this
Creepy Pasta Legend is the one that
captures you no end house in recent
years there's been a spike in interest
in so-called extreme haunted houses if
you're not sure what these places are
like basically picture a CIA black site
with the occasional plastic skeleton
it's all waterboarding stress positions
and car batteries but even those places
are nothing compared to the nightmare of
no end house it's a moving possibly even
sentient spatial anomaly hiding in a
haunted house attraction and if you find
yourself inside best believe you're
never going to see the outside ever
again thankfully mobile task force Delta
35 Mam's Bane are on the case around
Halloween every year they use web
crawlers to detect chatter around no end
House events so they can swoop in and
intercept preventing Hess Thrill Seekers
from being devoured by the house and
providing amnestic treatment for any one
who has too close of a call sadly the
foundation will not be able to provide
refunds for those who already paid
speaking of paying you'll really pay if
you end up in our next Creepy Pasta
location of Doom abandoned by Disney
mowgli's kingdom an abandoned tropical
Disney attraction based on The Jungle
Book movie is abandoned for a reason
it's a hot bed for anomalous activity
including freakishly large mutant snakes
reports of ghost activity and most
prominent of all a terrifying Photon
negative Mickey Mouse that stalks any
hapless Urban explorers who happen to
find their way onto the site of course
the Walt Disney Corporation keeps it all
hush hush and the SCP Foundation is
happy to give them a hand on that front
even if the frightening photo negative
Mickey was removed from the site it's
likely the other may appear and continue
haunting the site and seeing that the
site cannot be moved as a whole the
foundation 's best bet is to form a
perimeter around the abandoned Disney
attraction preventing anything normal
from getting in and anything abnormal
from getting out mobile task force Omega
17 sons of shikan are ever Vigilant and
maintain a strong presence in the
surrounding area but you don't need to
go anywhere for this next anomalous
Terror if you're a big Nintendo fan it
might be sitting in your house right now
Ben Drowned this haunted NES cartridge
of The Legend of Zelda Majora's Mask
contains the Restless Spirit of its last
owner a guy named Ben who well drowned
if you slot This creepy little gaming
experience into your Nintendo
Entertainment System you'll soon find
that the soul of Ben is communicating
with you directly telling you about how
he died and why his Consciousness
lingers on embedded in the code of the
game thankfully other than the
psychological trauma of experiencing the
game your unlikely to be actually harmed
by playing it however mobile task force
beta 51 Gamers don't have rights are
still on the case they'll try to
intercept all cursed copies of the game
and administer amnestics to anyone who
is unfortunate enough to play it while
it is still undeniably spooky it does
feel like a relief to finally find a
safe class anomaly on this list the same
can sadly not be said about our next
creature the Goatman if you're a fan of
camp then this malicious mimic is going
to be your worst nightmare this monster
has existed as a fixture of Terror in
everything from a number of Native
American mythologies to iconic 4chan
greenex posts you may be thinking oh
What's So Scary About a goat but this
thing is no goat aside from the fact
that it's the greatest of all time at
getting you to crap your cargo shorts in
the woods first you'll smell blood in
the air and then feel an odd electrical
static like the feeling all around
around you right before a lightning
strike then you'll hear noises strange
noises something not quite like a voice
like an animal throat straining to form
human words that's when you might notice
your group of friends has one more
person than you remembered and the one
thing worse than noticing that is not
noticing it because if you don't you may
end up as the shape-shifting goatman's
latest victim mobile task force Theta 11
got your gun note are constantly on the
hunt for this one but its extreme
intelligence and ethereal nature make it
a nightmare to track but forget
nightmares to track it's time for
Laughing Jack this candy stripe clown
from hell is a really nasty customer
definitely do not engage unless you've
got a Scranton reality anchor on hand
and you've got a backup from members of
mobile task force Iota 40 put Jack in
the Box as a former imaginary friend
gone Rogue Laughing Jack is a semi
intangible reality warper of
considerable power he targets his
victims with sadistic Glee pulling them
into his dark carnival to experience all
kinds of nasty tortures Laughing Jack
shows No Remorse giggling while
committing every evil act you can
imagine you'll probably only find this
clown funny if you're already a depraved
serial killer and his sense of humor is
likely to utterly break your mind unless
you've been given amnestic treatment
from the SCP Foundation this is an
anomaly that would probably get along
swimmingly with SCP 106 the old man they
could chat over a few drinks one evening
and share notes on how to cause the
maximum pain to their hapless victims
that being said few people understand
maximum pain more than the next
horrifying Abomination on our roster the
Russian sleep experiment test subjects
as anyone familiar with the work of Gru
division P will tell you the Soviets
performed some pretty horrific occult
activities throughout the 20th century
one of the most disturbing of these was
the infamous Russian sleep experiment
where in a group of unfortunate
political prisoners were doused on a
classified anomalous gas that robbed
them of their ability to sleep a
chemical compound that the scientists
hope might increase the productivity of
their workers and Soldiers by
eliminating sleep instead over several
terrifying days the chemical and the
sleep deprivation that ensued caused the
subjects to instead become demonic
monsters while current accounts of the
story suggest that all the subjects were
killed we can't say for sure there
weren't more out there or that the
experiment hasn't been repeated as such
mobile task force Omicron 8 night night
is constantly on the lookout for
freakish skeletal men wandering through
the woods never sleeping outside the
dark forests where Siberian Googs used
to be based better safe than saring
right though of course you won't feel
safe at all if you spent your childhood
watching scaring media like horror
movies or eie SCP YouTube channels like
And subscribe by the way or scariest of
all a strange little puppet show called
Candle Cove feel a little chill go down
your spine oh yes you remember this show
don't you you love seeing all those cute
little puppets going on swashbuckling
pirate Journeys on their adorable boat
the laughing stock though there was
always that villain wasn't there you
think his name was Jawbone but that's
not what you called him you called him
the skin taker because he always had
that long cloak made of tanned human
skin you also remember that one episode
that was just all the characters
screaming I mean how could you possibly
forget and most of all you remember
asking your mom about it and her telling
you that you never actually watched a
show called Candle Cove you just sat
around watching static for hours on end
of course the SCP Foundation keeps close
tabs on everything related to this
traumatic childhood memory broadcasts of
the show are seemingly impossible to
contain all the foundation can really do
is track down people who have seen it
and provide amnestic treatment though
trust us there are things that will make
your childhood far worse than just
watching Candle Cove like running into
this next iconic monster the Slender Man
this terrifying entity is powerful as he
is Iconic a shape-shifting faceless
tentacled Nightmare and a three piece
suit who likes to hide in forests and
abandon buildings either stealing
children away or influencing their minds
until they become his proxies
Supernatural servants who do anything
their inhuman Master asks them to the
Slenderman is one of the most powerful
monsters in all of creepy pasta so the
foundation certainly has their hands
full with keeping his tentacles Under
Wraps all that mobile task force ch90
Marble Hornets can do is track sightings
and keep children out of the woods when
the danger of potential Slenderman
encounters arises getting him actually
contained basically seems out of the
question after all this we might need to
relax maybe grabbing a nice sugar-free
soda and playing a session of Minecraft
might make us feel better we'll be safe
there right well probably unless we
encounter
Herobrine the SCP Foundation funnily
enough is actually no stranger to
anomalies trapped in Minecraft they've
got SCP 4335 a welt in The Crucible to
thank for that but this Minecraft horror
story is a little more personal
Herobrine is a mysterious user with the
Minecraft default skin except with one
difference completely white eyes this
mysterious figure invades different
Minecraft servers acting incredibly
strange towards the people who created
them
what makes this more than just some
random troll well according to Legends
Herobrine is the manifestation of the
Dead Brother of Minecraft's creator
Notch naturally the foundation doesn't
want people running into ghosts on
Minecraft so they dispatch mobile task
force
ch69 blocked and reported to quarantine
any servers where Herobrine is cited and
spread misinformation that the crafty
little entity had never actually existed
in the first place what is the truth of
the situation it's unclear and that's
exactly how the foundation likes it so
there we have it folks how the SCP
Foundation would counteract some of the
most infamous Creepy Pasta creeps and
creatures out there which was your
favorite do we miss any and would you
like to see any of these expanded into a
full video in the future let us know
down in the comments if you
[Laughter]
dare the woman fell to the ground
clutching her ankle in pain it had
crunched badly as she'd fallen and now
as she looked down at it she could see
that it was been totally out of shape
the heavy metal collar choking her neck
made it difficult for her to catch her
breath as she tried her best not to
hyperventilate the rain was hammering
down so ferociously that she could
barely see more than 20 ft in any
direction but she didn't need to see far
to know how deadly of a predicament she
had found herself in she cried out at
the top of her voice for someone to come
and find her anyone but the only sound
that filled her ears was the wild
howling of the wind and the steady
hammering of water into the bog all
around her she would get hypothermia and
die no wait she couldn't could she she
knew she couldn't die but she also knew
that she was still capable of suffering
just how bad would it feel to be in the
clutches of hypothermia with a broken
ankle and know that no matter how bad
the pain and suffering got she would
never feel the release of death she
closed her eyes trying her best not to
think of the worst possibilities just as
the sound of gunfire erupted in the
nearby buffer she cried out again
holding both hands up in the air doing
the best she could around the heavy
metal collar but no one shouted out in
reply there was a pause in the gunfire
maybe they'd heard her maybe they were
trying to figure out a way to come down
and rescue her crack a bullet split open
a rotted tree trunk just a few feet to
her right the woman threw her hands over
her head and cowered in the dirt feeling
the metal of her collar digging into her
skin tighter than ever please don't let
it happen again she prayed silently into
the dirt encased in the collar around
her neck were 4.5 kg of plastic
explosives each with a fragmentation
layer pointed inwards towards her neck
and head with just a push of a button
they could she didn't want to think
about it all she knew was that that she
couldn't let that happen to her again
looking through eyes bloodied with tears
and Rain she saw lying in the dirt just
a few feet away from her that infernal
machine that was the sorry cause of all
of this the SCP Foundation has long
stood as a Bastion of Hope information
and security for the entirety of the
human race I'm sure you are well aware
of the number of world destroying
catastrophes that have been adverted by
the hardworking researchers agents and
other members of the foundation all
without the general public having the
slightest clue that something was a Miss
with state-of-the-art holding cells all
over the globe and the sharpest Minds
Humanity has ever produced working
around the clock to ensure the
protection of humanity it is hard to
imagine an entity that should not be
contained by such a group and yet one
such entity does exist SCP
001 you may have come across the 05
Council by this point while the SCP
Foundation operates beyond the world's
jurisdiction the 05 Council operates
beyond the foundation's jurisdiction the
rules methods and protocols that are the
Cornerstone of securing containing and
protecting countless entities around the
world sometimes cannot be applied
certain entities require us to
temporarily abandon our Humanity abandon
our sense of order and step briefly into
chaos for the greater good I'm telling
you all of this because SCP 001 is not
held in a containment cell there are no
keypads locked doors observation windows
or health and safety forms SCP 001 is
not confined to a specific territory or
even a specific country for some scps
this is a practical necessity serpents
that are hundreds of kilometers long
swimming through the depths of the ocean
for example but for SCP 001 it serves a
more cyc ological purpose the Scottish
Highlands are the most remote part of
the United Kingdom out there you can
walk for miles and miles without seeing
a single soul open Countryside mountains
locks and forests surround you in all
directions the weather is Harsh and
unrelenting the walking even more so on
a regular basis Walkers fall and break
their legs but without phone service or
anyone else nearby to come and help they
can quickly disappear into the
Wilderness forever the p bogs of
Scotland used to see human sacrifices in
early settlements afraid of the ghosts
and spirits that haunted the bogs people
would throw their family members into
the deepest parts and watch them drown
hoping that whatever was lurking beneath
wouldn't come and find them so as the
group of soldiers crusted the top of the
mountain and looked down beneath them to
the Eerie Pete bogs obscured by mist and
constant rainfall you would forgive a
shiver running up their spines but of
course it didn't that was because this
group of soldiers were quite unlike any
others that Humanity has ever produced
all were nameless none of them existed
on any government databases on any
foundation databases or even on the
databases of the 05 Council itself their
individual backgrounds nationalities and
families were totally unknown to
everyone other than themselves some had
been tortured for years others had been
the torturers the thing that United them
however was their inhuman ruthlessness a
squad of eight soldiers utterly devoid
of any sense of empathy what could they
possibly have to be afraid of in the
Pete bogs when they themselves were the
evil ghosts walking through but then one
person was afraid a shiver ran up her
spine as she looked over the edge and
down into the murky black and green
below SCP
01-1 around her neck was the bomb collar
each of the eight soldiers surrounding
her had a button mounted on a watch on
the back of their wrists at any moment
any one of them could hit the button and
all 4 and 1 12 kg of plastic explosives
would go off sending her on an Express
trip to Oblivion aside from the collar
she wore a plain white dress made of
cotton it was muddy and torn apart at
the Hem from Days of walking through the
Scottish Wilderness when she had first
arrived she had begged those around her
to supply rep her with some warm clothes
something practical that would keep her
comfortable and Stave off any illness
her requests however had not been
acknowledged clutching in her trembling
outstretched hands was the machine SCP
001 d a from its external experience you
would think it was nothing more than a
wooden box a perfect cuboid made from
glossy dark wood there were no symbols
no seams no latches nothing to indicate
any method of operation when the woman
in the machine had first been delivered
into the hands of the 05 Council the
researchers had spent weeks and millions
of dollars trying to activate the
machine their best scientists had
scanned for every possible form of
radiation and tried every method they
could conceive to stimulate the box into
opening the ultimate failed attempt
involved traveling to North Korea where
they negotiated placing the Box 20 cm
beneath a small nuclear warhead in
return for granting the dictatorship ke
key information on how to construct such
a weapon as we have established the 05
Council operates Beyond any kind of
jurisdiction yet at the bottom of the
irradiated crater set a perfectly intact
wooden box that was cooled to the touch
and showed no signs of radioactivity
only one person could interact with the
box and unearth the secrets that were
inside SC cp0011dx
a gun jabbed her in the back forcing her
to continue moving she had asked the
soldiers around her how much longer they
had to walk that day but none of them
had replied they never did in the 6
years that she had been held hostage by
this tiny militia she had never once
heard any of them say a word not even to
each other perhaps it was this
telepathic understanding that seemed to
run between them that unnerved her the
most despite having never spoken to each
other each Soldier seemed to understand
the others intimately and she had no
doubt that any one of the eight would
press the button on their wrist at a
moment's notice sadly for her she knew
this from experience the incident
happened four years ago now as the group
was traveling through Patagonia it was a
day almost identical to the one she was
having now they had been transported by
a helicopter flown by one of the eight
into the middle of the Wilderness there
they had marched for days without saying
a single word exhaustion had overtaken
her legs and she stumbled to the ground
unfortunately for her this happened
slightly too close to the female soldier
in front of her her knees hadn't even
hit the ground before the blast went off
the woman didn't remember it of course
how could she in an instant her mind had
been utterly destroyed what she did
remember was the next 18 months as her
body slowly healed itself one brain cell
at a time it wasn't so much like waking
up from a nightmare it was more con
constructing a nightmare slowly
alongside your Consciousness as neuron
by neuron your brain reformed itself
each individual celf screaming in Terror
at what had happened to it they had her
marching again before she was fit to
move her motor controls had been all
over the place she had fallen over
regularly and the terror of having one
of the soldiers pushed the button again
engulfed her with every movement and yet
Perhaps the most incredible thing about
SCP
0011 was the fact that if you had asked
her if she should have been held in this
kind of containment she would
immediately have agreed without batting
an I the only person incapable of
opening the box she recognized how
dangerous her existence was only she had
seen into the mysteries of the Box only
she had seen the horrors laid inside of
it and so only she could fully
understand the gravity of their
situation they kept her on the Move in
order to keep the world safe had she
been held in a containment cell she
would have posed too great of a risk out
here in the wilderness the entire planet
was her containment cell hidden in the
middle of Humanity's biggest hay stack
no one not even the 05 council's Central
Command knew her location the only
people who were aware of it at any given
time were herself and the eight soldiers
surrounding her with guns drawn so you
can imagine her horror when out of the
Sheets of Rain appeared the figure of a
person carrying a rifle the gunfire
broke out before SCP 00 1-1 even had a
chance to hit the ground bullets whizzed
through her hair and cracked open the
Rocks all around her the aid soldiers
surrounding her die for cover as the
figure in the rain slumped to the ground
lifeless one of the soldiers grabbed the
woman by her explosive collar and threw
her behind a rock clasping her hands
over her ears she closed her eyes and
waited for the fight to be over no one
was shooting until a second figure
emerged from the rain waving their arms
wildly gunfire again she wasn't quite
sure what had happened but all of a
sudden the woman was falling down the
cliff she had just been trying to shift
her position to get deeper into cover
but she clearly hadn't noticed just how
close to the edge she was down and down
and down she fell until with a crack in
her ankle she landed in the peep bog
gunfire cracked on the mountain above
her but the only thought that filled the
woman's mind was the terror that at any
moment the explosive collar around her
neck would be detonated as one of the
soldiers above her realized that she was
missing seconds passed as the fear
mounted in her chest with each passing
moment the anxiety grew more and more
crippling she had to know she had to
prepare herself if it was about to
happen she had to use the machine and
look into the future dragging herself
forward through the muck the woman
snatched at the wooden box it came alive
at her touch different pieces shifted
and open beneath her fingers like some
kind of elaborate puzzle no one had
taught her how to use this thing it just
happened her fingers would just dance
across its surfaces pushing and pulling
opening and closing twisting and turning
and locking into place until all of a
sudden there it was the box was wide
open in front of her taking a deep
breath and allowing the rain to fall on
her head for another brief moment the
woman leaned forward and stepped into
the box on the trail above her the
gunfire stopped but without a word of
communication the soldiers had deafly
flanked the group of people who had
approached them in less than a minute
they neutralized each individual that
came their way in unison the group of
them walked up to the bodies turning
them over to examine their faces they
were nobody's just a group of hikers
lost in the rain what had looked like a
gun turned out to be nothing more than a
walking pole five of them in total none
of them older than 24 without words the
soldiers picked up the bodies and threw
them over their shoulders as they
scrambled their way down The Cliffs to
the woman in the machine beneath them
once they reached the bottom of the
slope they discarded the five bodies
carelessly into the bog within a couple
of hours those five hikers would have
sunk to the bottom and begun the long
process of being embalmed into the
deaths perhaps someone would find them
in a few thousand years time as part of
an archaeological dig perhaps but it was
not their concern the eight soldiers
surrounded the women guns drawn and
stared at her coldly I use the machine
she told them I used it without your
permission I I don't know what the rules
are I don't know if we even have any
rules here but I I thought you should
know the soldiers continued to look at
her in Silence the box was closed now
sitting back on her lap as it always was
I I try to see my future anytime I've
used the Box before I've looked at the
lives of others I've seen economic
crashes climate disasters genocides Wars
love and life and death I've done so at
the hands of the 05 Council as they've
told me given them the information and
prevented the destruction of the world
now never once have I looked at my own
future the soldiers lifted her to her
feet and tried to March her onwards not
listening to a word she was saying her
broken ankle buckled and screamed
beneath her she had to hop to keep up
with them what other choice did she have
they would push the button if she didn't
she didn't know why she kept talking but
she did For the First Time The Machine
lied to me I saw that I was assassinated
in 1987 in Cuba it was years before I
even built the Box before any of this
happened to me I saw in my future that I
no longer existed that the machine no
longer existed but that future was years
ago and none of it happened the machine
doesn't lie so why is it lying to me now
why can't I see my own future if any of
the soldiers were paying attention they
didn't show it they just continued to
March her into the rain as the bomb
weighed heavily around her neck roll up
roll up Step Right This Way ladies and
gentlemen on the other side of these
canvas doors you're about to witness
something so monstrous so hideous so
repulsive that it will turn your
stomachs and fill you with amazement the
creature you'll find in this tent has
been known to elit all manner of
responses from well-to-do folks like
yourselves you may want to laugh at it
you may want to strike it down you may
even want to throw rotten fruit at it
and believe you me we are prepared for
that you will find all manner of Rotten
Tomatoes eggs and other festering foods
that are begging to be pelted for the
low low price of 5 cents per handful if
you follow me through these doors and
gather around this cage quietly perhaps
you will see it wait for your eyes to
adjust to the dark and hold your
revulsion until you cannot bear it
anymore only then will we get to look at
the papery gray skin sagging loose over
a swollen gut Marvel at its three trunk
legs barely strong enough to support its
own weight its deformed trunk that hangs
limp off the front of its face and its
ridiculous ears that flap nervously when
it's afraid don't don't be afraid of the
Tusk sticking out from its face or its
cries of pain and anguish instead hold
your tongues and wait for if you're
patient enough and perhaps with a slight
beating it may even play us a song with
the valves on its trunk then and only
then you're permitted to pel the
Elephant Man with whatever you see fit
as you bask in the glory of Herman
Fuller's circus of the disquieting Reese
Freeman didn't have much of a choice but
to join the circus at the age of 14
the cast out son of a freed slave in New
Orleans he spent much of his early life
wandering the streets trying not to get
into any trouble in the late 1800s very
few places were interested in hiring a
young black man unless of course they
were looking to turn him back to the
life that his father had fought so hard
to escape that's why when ree was out
fishing one afternoon and saw a big red
tent going up on the outskirts of town
he couldn't help but Wander Over much to
his surprise a group of black men were
were the ones raising the Marquee they
didn't look like slaves either Reese had
never heard of a circus the closest he'd
ever come to see was a traveling
entertainment cart that would sometimes
pop up around town with a dancing bear
in a cage or a glass ball in a pack of
tarot cards the brightly colored tents
that went up one after another were
enough to draw a crowd even the most
well-respected in New Orleans came out
for a look standing ankled deep in the
river Reese peered over at the man who
came out to address the throng dressed
in a long tail coat with a tall Top Hat
the man stood on a box of fruit and
waved a cane dramatically in the air
good folks of New Orleans what you're
about to witness tonight has never
before been seen this side of the
Mississippi wonders and amazement Galore
spectacle in intri Mystery in Mayhem and
just a touch of the impossible I go by
the name of Herman Fuller the most
talented and notorious circus master in
the entire United States the dazzling
array of shows that I've brought before
you is not for the faint of heart or the
weak of constitution your stomachs will
be turned and your minds may be altered
but it promises to be a knight that you
will never forget Reese wasn't much
interested in any of what he had just
said this kind of Two Penny show was
reserved for the folks who had the money
to throw around on needless things like
smiling and having a nice evening what
Reese was far more interested in were
the groups of men working behind the
scenes pulling various carts and setting
up all of the Stalls a lot of them
didn't look much older than him a grin
spread across his face SCP 4409 insisted
on being interviewed in the dark with
all the lights in the interview chamber
Switched Off Dr Simon Crossley entered
the room and sat down across from the
Elephant Man even in the dim light
though he was able to still make out
part of the man's features the ivory
tusks the hanging nose and the nervously
twitching ears the man had been picked
up in St Louis where local police had
found him panhandling in the streets
while he certainly seemed harmless
enough it was important for the
foundation to take him in just to be
sure sitting in the dark interview room
reys Freeman was apprehensive at first
about telling his side of the story a
life of being mocked spat on and chased
out of towns had left him with a real
distrust of other people that was
probably made worse by his appr
attention at being put in another cage
within the foundation he told Dr
Crossley that he was born as normal as
could be that his current ghastly
Affliction was something done to him
quite some time ago but as much as it
pained him to recollect it was a tale
that he knew he'd probably have to tell
Dr Crossley replied that he was all ears
it took Dr Crossley a few seconds to
realize his FAA SCP 4409 glared at him
before continuing to explain how he was
made the way he was Rees Freeman had
managed to land a job with the circus
surprisingly easily despite having no
previous experience and no references to
back him up Herman Fuller took a shine
to him it was menial work and not many
folks were up to doing it but since
Reese had never had a job before he
didn't know any better he started out at
the bottom of the ladder scraping out
feces washing down old cages and
carrying heavy crates the one scrawny
14-year-old boy quickly turned into a
stocky 17-year-old with broad shoulders
and strong legs they would travel from
town to town across most of the United
States stopping off in major cities for
weeks at a time to bring in as much
money as possible before moving on Reese
didn't save much of that money but he
didn't mind the fact that he got two
meals a day and something to do with
himself was enough in fact he kind of
enjoyed sleeping on top of the carts as
the horses pulled them across the dusty
American roads the one thing that always
seemed to affect him though was that he
was never allowed to actually see inside
the tents he would see folks come and go
through the canvas doors week after week
but was never allowed so much as a peak
inside himself the older guys were
responsible for throwing the canvas
sheets over the cages which would remain
that way as they traveled not having
seen much of the world at that point
Reese didn't have much of an idea of
what could be in those cages perhaps
some kind of animal from a foreign
country something from Africa or Asia
they made all kinds of noise Reese said
that most of them sounded like humans
but then they'd go and make strange
animal sounds that no human mouth could
ever produce one night his curiosity got
the better of him hanging back before
the crowds got into the tent he Sid
stepped over to the entrance making sure
that no one saw him and took a peek
through the doorway it was dark inside
too dark to make out much of what was
happening the crowd of people was
standing between him and the cage all
jostling and leaning this way and that
trying to make out whatever it was that
was inside a screeching sound filled the
air making the whole crowd and Reese
outside jump right standing on his
tiptoes he tried his best to see what
was moving around in that cage it seemed
to be moving around like a person
lurching this way and that but the
sounds coming from it sounded more like
a bird and sure enough after a moment a
huge pair of disproportionately ugly
Wings stretched out from either side of
the creature flapping and sending a rush
of air air through the tent so powerful
that it blew the flap wide open in front
of him just as Herman Fuller turned
around to see him standing there ree
bolted and hid behind one of the carts
he was going to be in trouble for this
he was sure of it it was one of Fuller's
only rules of the circus and he had just
gone and broken it he was in the hottest
water imaginable but as nighttime fell
and the drags of the spectators wandered
out of the tent Fuller seemed to be in
too bad a mood at all while watching him
from a distance reys got the impression
that he might not actually be in as much
trouble as he thought Fuller caught his
eye and came over Kane twirling and Top
Hat sitting jauntily at top his head
Rees got off on the wrong foot
apologizing right away for spying into
the tent the circus Master just laughed
it off and slapped him on the back Reese
my boy don't worry about it I've got
much bigger plans for you much much
bigger that night as Reese lay in bed he
had a terrible dream about what he had
seen in the tent that day circus of the
disquieting was certainly an apt title
for this place the image of that strange
shadowy bird person in the cage haunted
his nightmares until suddenly two pairs
of strong hands gripped him and ripped
him out of his sleep he knew better than
to fight back this was surely going to
be his comeuppence for breaking Fuller's
rules earlier they dragged him into the
main tent where there was an oil lamp in
the middle Illuminating what looked like
a heavy wooden operating table his
wrists and ankles were strapped in and
then the two men left him alone he had
half a mind to scream but with all the
Caged up creatures from the circus
around him he doubted anyone would pay
him much mind it was almost an hour
before Herman Fuller walked into the
tent by this point reys expected him to
be walking in with surgical equipment
gloves maybe even a saw but the man had
nothing in his bare hands Herman Fuller
asked him if he ever heard of Joseph
Merrick Reese didn't answer of of course
he had heard of the Elephant Man the
whole world had been talking about
Joseph Merrick for months a man born so
hideously deformed that people had
compared him to an elephant though the
resemblance wasn't that convincing this
sentiment was clearly shared by Fuller
who placed one hand on either side of
rees's face and began to softly massage
his cheeks explaining how disappointed
he was that Merck didn't actually look
all that much like an elephant Reese's
cheeks started to hurt as the man Mass
AED him almost as if he was stretching
and pulling at his face finding loose
skin the boy asked Fuller what he was
doing the circus Master just smiled at
him and explained that it was an old
technique handed down in his family a
gift he called it he started touching
Reese's nose gently pulling at it with
more and more pressure much to Reese's
surprise he felt his nose elongating
growing longer and longer in the man's
hand he tried to Twitch his face and was
starting to find that his new nose
twitched along with it the longer it
grew the more painful it felt the skin
and flesh from his head being ripped and
pulled into a new shape at several
points Reese felt ready to pass out from
the agony but the circus Master kept
talking to him kept him awake through
the whole ordeal as he molded the boy's
face like clay into the shape of an
elephant lying on the bench panting reys
could see his trunk from between his two
eyes it was a nightmare that was all it
was but then Fuller reached under the
workbench and lifted out a small hand
drill one by one he punched holes into
the top of Reese's trunk installing
little valves like a trumpet as he went
standing back to admire his handiwork he
told Reese that he would be his new
favorite attraction my boy I have made
you into a star the tusks did not come
straight away over the course of several
months they slowly and painfully emerged
from his deformed jaw his elephantine
legs were also not part of his initial
transformation but instead came as a
result of health issues he developed
while being trapped in a cage for
several decades crowds of people would
come and go flocking to see the Elephant
Man having spent the first part of his
life constantly hungry Reese was now
being overfed every day hands would come
to his cage and force him to eat Rich
fatty foods denying him any possibility
of exercise the broad shoulders and
strong legs that he had developed while
working at the circus melted away under
layers and layers of fat his skin went
gray and papery folding and wrinkling in
on itself either from Fuller's magic or
just from a lack of sunlight whatever it
was with every passing day reys Freeman
steadily became more and more hideous
SCP 4409 was stuck in the circus for
much of his life eventually Herman
Fuller moved on and is currently being
hunted by the SCP Foundation when he did
SCP 4409 was able to bargain for its
freedom from the circus wandering from
City to City never sticking around for
very long SCP 4409 begged for change at
the side of the road some people would
feel sympathy While most would feel
horror at its disfigurement from its
years trapped in a cage SCP 449 has
developed severe health issues including
gout severe obesity and metabolic
syndrome while in Foundation custody it
is fed a special diet to counteract
these conditions as of yet the
foundation has no way of reversing what
was done to Reese Freeman in the tent in
the 1800s as Reese poses no threat to
the foundation he is allowed to live
with relative Freedom or at least as
much Freedom as a contained SCP can earn
his health condition severely limits his
Mobility around site 66 a low security
residential containment area unable to
walk even moderate distances SCP 4409
heavily relies on the use of a cane and
a heavyduty walker capable of supporting
up to 140 kg researchers listen intently
at his door waiting to hear if he's ever
going to play a sad song on his trumpet
but no sound ever emerges except for his
heavy breathing and spluttering coughs
it appears that having spent decades
locked in a small cage a sedentary life
is all he knows now with every
opportunity to exercise read books and
take up new hobbies SCP 449 appears
unable to engage with anything other
than sitting and staring at the same
spot on the wall every day if an animal
has spent its whole life living in a zoo
and finds in its old age that one of the
walls has fallen down what use has it in
taking a step outside it had been a long
day Expeditions like this were normally
tiring but with the intense heat of the
Egyptian sun bearing down on them every
minute felt like hours and every hour a
lifetime time Seth and Kayla were
determined not to quit they had traveled
Halfway Around the World to get to this
site and they weren't about to let the
elements stopped them from uncovering
the secrets they were searching for the
rumors had dated back centuries stories
of a hidden tomb lost somewhere out in
the desert and as a likely pair of
budding Adventurer and an accomplished
archaeologist neither one of them could
resist the chance to try and hunt down
the tomb if they could uncover it they'd
have one of the greatest AR
archeological finds of the century on
their hands both Kayla and Seth would
forever be remembered as the ones who
discovered a supposedly unfindable
ancient tomb having found their way to
some ruins the remains of a temple that
had been all but raised to the ground
ravaged by the forces of time Kayla and
Seth had started searching for the
tomb's entrance the reason it had stayed
uncovered for so long was the amount of
sand that had covered it over the
centuries storms from the desert
constantly rearranging the grains and
piling on more but right now the skies
were clear and all they could do was
keep digging until at long last their
shovels struck Stone clearing a path to
the entrance Kayla flipped on a torch as
she led her archaeologist friend down a
flight of stairs carved into the stone
Seth followed her as they traversed
further and further down the air getting
stale the deeper they went the whole
while there was a gwing concern at the
back of both of their minds that The
Rock Rocky ceiling above could give way
at any moment trapping them both
underground but before each of them
could voice their worry out loud they
arrived at a large stone door left wide
open about 20 M beneath the surface is
this really it Kayla asked in disbelief
it might be Seth replied the excitement
in his voice like that of a kid on
Christmas morning standing before them
beyond the threshold of the open
entrance was a chamber of stone its
ceiling was Secure about 7 m High and
the walls had been covered in
hieroglyphics immediately Seth shot over
to the nearest wall pulling a battered
Journal out of his bag to start to try
to translate what had been written while
he was doing that Kayla's attention fell
over the rest of the room for a tomb
there was a surprising lack of a
sarcophagus nor any other similar
resting place for a body with no signs
that anyone else had already been here
to remove one either all there really
was within was a few bowls randomly
placed around the chamber Kayla's torch
light fell over one of the bowls and she
knelt down to take a closer look at its
contents it was filled with bread they
were all holding different foods dates
figs dried fish and lentils of course it
wasn't uncommon for offerings to be left
with the deceased during an ancient
Egyptian burial but strangely none of
these perishable foods seem to have
decayed in the centuries this tomb had
been lost for in fact it all looked
quite fresh like it was still good
enough to eat although the temptation to
actually eat any of it quickly
disappeared when Kayla reminded herself
that while it might not look it the food
down here had to have been hundreds
maybe thousands of years old despite how
perfectly preserved it appeared I think
I've got something Seth called
enthusiastically there's definitely a
story in these hieroglyphics you sure
we're in the right place Kayla asked as
she crossed the room to where her
colleague was for a tomb it doesn't seem
like anyone was ever buried here I've
Got a Theory he replied this place might
be more of a metaphorical tomb right
that makes complete sense her sarcasm
was unmistakable look here he said
pointing to one of the drawings on the
wall as he spoke it depicted a figure
laying dead in a square space I think
that's meant to be this room someone
dies here and then Seth's finger moved
to another of the hieroglyphics one that
Kayla recognized it showed a being with
the body of a man and the head of a
jackal taking the dead figure down into
the Afterlife this was Anubis one of the
ancient Egyptian gods associated with
the afterlife according to Legends and
other texts gathered from the pyramids
in Giza Anubis oversaw the process the
Egyptians would perform to embal their
dead preserving them for their trip to
the next World Anubis takes whoever they
are to the Judgment Hall of the
afterlife to be brought before Seth
explained only to be cut off Osiris God
of fertility the afterlife and the dead
Kayla interrupted she had already
spotted the next being depicted in the
glyph a tall figure with a distinctive
headpiece holding a symbolic Crook and
flail oversaw Resurrection Life probably
many other things yeah he was a god with
a few different hats Seth attempted to
joke well just the same one hat he's
always shown wearing also technically
not a hat the ATI was a type of crown
and so hold on Killa interjected again
didn't Osiris only bring the Pharaohs in
for judgment who was this person that
died I mean the Egyptians never went to
this amount of trouble for their Average
Joe's and the gods wouldn't pay them any
mind unless they were important somehow
I'm not sure Seth answered earnestly at
any rate this could all just be a myth
that's why I think this tomb is
metaphorical it wasn't built to house a
dead person but to keep people believing
she finished his sentence for him he
then pointed out the next part of the
glyphs the dead figure arriving in the
afterlife carried by Anubis for judgment
and then handing an object to Osiris
Seth explained there was a certain myth
surrounding Osiris and his resurrection
a story that told of all of his dead
body parts being found except one
without it the God could not be fully
resurrected my theory is that is
Osiris's missing appendage as it were
Seth's face was red as he tried to keep
his composure after our mysterious
friend handed it over the hieroglyphs
showed the nameless dead figure being
taken from anubis' Hand by Osiris who
then placed them back in the room they
had started in the same chamber Seth and
Kayla were standing in it seemed they
had been resurrected after death giving
Osiris something that the God had wanted
had earned this figure a free pass back
to the land of the living the glyphs
also showed bowls of food around the
tomb like the ones Kayla had found
dotted around the room there was a type
of Aura drawn around the unknown figure
now almost like a personal Shield
according to the drawings and symbols on
the walls and Seth's hastily translation
of their meaning this was some form of
protection granted by Osiris himself the
ARA was meant to prevent the figure from
harm meaning they couldn't die again
however the next portion of the story
showed Anubis damaging The Shield
possibly out of jealousy or spite or
perhaps defying Osiris tampering with
the natural Order of Things by
protecting the figure from Death as well
as causing damage to the aura of
immortality that Osiris had bestowed
upon them a nubis drained the figure of
all of their blood which then caused
them to go and do the same to us
Seth continued interpreting aloud they
would find people drink their blood to
sustain it like don't say it Kayla
sighed I mean it's a lot like a Egypt
gave us mummies they can't have another
native monster from horror be movies she
interrupted well maybe the legend found
its way here somehow or at least a more
ancient Egyptian version of it her
counterpart tried to reason it looks
like here the figure was Far healthier
after consuming blood see how the aura
around them is repaired now but Seth
look at what they're standing on Kayla
whispered one of the final images in the
glyphs did display exactly what Seth had
described but beneath the feet of the
figure who now seemed replenished was a
mass of bodies a pile of human corpses
with one person standing at the very top
who'd want to live forever anyway Kayla
muttered almost inaudibly hey come and
have a look at these leaning over she
picked up one of the food bowls from the
floor brimming with offerings of dates
she handed it to Seth who marveled at
how well preserved the food was that's
incredible he remarked this bulll looks
like it's at least several thousand
years old I guess maybe 2500 BC but the
dates he poked one out of the bowl and
sniffed it put it back and then did the
same with another making sure it wasn't
a fluke the conditions couldn't possibly
have kept them fresh so how is it there
are bowls of food all over this room
that still look edible she asked I
honestly have no he began to say but the
sound of heavy grinding stone
interrupted Seth's sentence both he and
Kayla looked in horror as they witnessed
the entrance of the Tomb being sealed
the heavy stone door dropping moments
away from sealing them in Seth we need
to run Kayla urged grabbing her bag if
we move now we can get out of here
before we get shut in but Seth protested
looking around the tomb the glyph walls
that had only just been discovered
nobody would know that he and Kayla had
found them if they ran now he looked
around the room pondering for a moment
his eyes darting from a bowl of bread to
the bowl of dates in his hands we should
at least take photos no time our lives
aren't worth proving what we found
better to make it out than be buried
alive Kayla shouted darting towards the
entrance ducking under the slowly
lowering stone door Seth come on she
called from the other side despite her
calls for him to move her fellow
Explorer didn't follow he just stood
there watching the door get lower and
the only way back to the surface get
narrower by the time it had completely
closed Kayla's voice sounded so much
further away that Seth could barely make
out what she was saying I'll get help
find some way to get get you out Kayla
screamed at the wall now separating her
from the tomb if you can hear me Seth
ration the water in your bag take small
sips every few hours Seth already knew
that the human body could survive around
3 weeks on just water and no food and he
trusted Kayla would have figured out how
to get him out by then he gave another
glance to the food bowls scattered
throughout the tomb the idea of eating
any of it knowing how old it all
potentially was did turn his stomach a
little but if it came down to having to
eat just a bite in order to survive a
little longer Seth was sure it looked
fresh enough to still be edible it
couldn't hurt to take a bite right over
the next few days Seth's Focus was spent
entirely on photographing and
transcribing more of the hieroglyphics
occasionally stopping to take swigs of
water from his canteen if anything it
was more to combat how warm and stuffy
it was being locked inside the stone
chamber 20 M underground meanwhile
unseen to Seth outside Kayla was working
tirelessly to try and figure out a way
to get the door open she had been been
searching for days for any sign or some
kind of switch or lever that would
unseal the chamber entrance there had to
be some mechanism that had caused the
stone door to shut itself in the first
place but there was nothing around that
looked like it fit that description as
much as she urged Seth to abandon his
archaeological finders keeper Pride
Kayla was hesitant to make the long
journey back across the desert to Cairo
to get help anyone she brought to the
dig site might claim the discovery as
their own and more to the point the more
time she spent traveling across the
desert for help the more time Seth would
spend trapped succumbing to gradual
dehydration and starvation little was
Kayla aware it was already too late Seth
hadn't been observing her warning about
managing the amounts of water he was
drinking and pretty soon his canteen was
empty he cursed himself annoyed for
being so involved in his discovery that
he'd now potentially put his own life at
risk but then he remembered the food
bowls kneeling down he picked up the
nearest one the the same bowl with all
the dates in it shaking his head at the
thought he put them back down again the
longer he waited the more Seth began to
worry that maybe Kayla had abandoned him
and if she had then he was faced with
the inevitability that he would die down
here lost and forgotten in an ancient
tomb underground he couldn't help but
find something ironic about the whole
thing he was going to die in a tomb
whose walls told the tale of a dead
person being brought back to life maybe
in a few hundred years more Arch
ologists would find this buried room and
think he was the one the tomb had been
constructed for even trying to put an
ironic spin on things wasn't enough to
give Seth much peace when staring down
the possibility he might not see the Sun
and walk above ground again and getting
closer to death is what made him want to
avoid it tempting him towards the blls
of food every time he tried to remind
himself not to touch any of it the pain
in his stomach swelled even greater
reminding him of his own hunger with no
clear view of the sky Seth had little
clue just how many days he'd been
trapped in the Tomb although he was sure
it was approaching the day four
threshold he couldn't survive much
longer beyond that point without eating
as the days dragged on he abandoned his
research and notetaking it was
impossible to focus on translating
hieroglyphics when he was in so much
pain aching from the Heat and having no
food or water exhaustion causing him to
pass out his body trying to conserve its
already limited reserves of energy
eventually Seth started trying to
rationalize eating at least a date or
two the food hadn't decomposed or rotted
at all even introducing air from outside
when the tomb was first open hadn't
changed the state of any of it at all
not the dates nor the bread or the fish
it still looked fresh and edible and
after God knows how long without eating
it was beginning to look all the more
appealing to the starving archaeologist
who cares if it had been there for a
thousand years or longer if Seth didn't
eat eat he knew he wouldn't last much
longer the moment he chewed on the first
date feeling it pass down his esophagus
passing from his mouth to his stomach
Seth immediately regretted giving in to
his need to eat his mouth instantly went
dry far worse than it had been after
this long without water it was like the
tiny piece of fruit had pulled all the
saliva from his mouth Seth tried to
scream and panic only to release aoar
dry throated grasp as he felt his tongue
shriveling up with his mouth and throat
until it felt like the skin of a drum
but it didn't stop there it only got
worse Seth stared in horror at his own
arms the blue veins that ran underneath
his skin rapidly draining away his
forearms and biceps shrunk muscle and
sineu shriveling like his body had been
left in a water evaporator all the while
the pain of having his entire physical
form being reshaped was pure Agony the
dehydration of his mouth meant Seth
still couldn't scream only dropped to
the ground as he felt the same same
thing happening to his legs every drop
of moisture in his body every fluid from
water to blood saliva and even urine was
drying out leaving Seth as little more
than a Dusty desiccated husk before his
own eyes he could only watch as his skin
lost its pigment drying into a thin
leathery texture drained of its original
color as his blood stopped flowing
outside Kayla had been coming back to
the tomb's sealed door every day and
would stay until the late hours of the
evening she tried digging down from the
surface to reach the chamber where Seth
had been trapped but it was too far
underground there was no sign of any way
to move or reopen the stone door that is
until she heard the heavy grinding of it
opening on its own Kayla raced down the
steps towards the tomb it had been five
whole days since she and Seth got
separated and he'd need food and medical
attention sprinting into the dark tunnel
she arrived just in time to see the
entrance reopening expecting to see Seth
standing on the other side as the stone
door lifted what she saw instead was a
nightmare it looked like a corpse an
ancient and decomposing dead body Kayla
had seen plenty intmed in sarcophagy on
her many travels exploring ancient ruins
around the world but she had never seen
one standing up it was still breathing a
wheezing raspy sound escaping its mouth
its skin looked almost brittle as if it
was stretched too thin almost
see-through enough to show off the bones
underneath the upright Corpse's face was
all wrong too sunken cheeks and eye
sockets deeper than they should have
been it looked so different that it
wasn't until Kayla shown her flashlight
on its drained face that she recognized
who it was Seth he lunged at her
immediately racing towards her snarling
with his dry desiccated mouth Kayla
turned and ran as he came after her bony
fingers swiping at her clothes her
flashlight gripped in her hand was all
but useless as she sprinted back the way
she'd come swinging back and forth in
her arm barely Illuminating much of the
cavern that led to the tomb the whole
while she was running from it she could
hear the wheezing behind of Seth behind
her terrified of whatever he had become
and why he was chasing her then she saw
it the stairs her one shot at getting
out and getting away if she could make
it to the surface she could put some
more distance between herself and the
drained dehydrated corpse all she had to
do was make it up the last step she had
just made it when she felt the
shriveling hand grip her ankle tripping
her over falling face first in the sand
Kayla scrabbled at the loose grains
trying to pull herself away as her body
was dragged back down onto the stone
stairs she felt a searing pain and
screamed into the empty desert as The
Corpse's fingers dug into her neck its
leathery dry skin against hers
eventually the screaming stopped
replaced with a dry horse gasping and
then silence as Seth drained her body of
her blood along with the rest pulling
Kayla's Body by her ankle Seth dragged
whatever was left of her back down
towards the tomb SCP
3359 to feed on what was left in 1914 an
arch Duke of Austria Hungary was shot by
a Serbian nationalist this led after a
series of Nations signing treaties with
other nations to one of the bloodiest
conflicts ever fought a war that was
unlike any that had been fought at the
time trench combat mud and sandbags
newer deadlier advancements in the art
of warfare vile incurable and fatal
diseases and months upon months of
Misery all while trapped in dark dank
dugouts the Great War the first world
war it's gone by many names since its
ceasefire in 1918 and while there aren't
many left of the generation that
remembers it there are still plenty of
scars left on the world that remind us
of the horrors but there's one that
seems to be keeping those wounds fresh
reminding us that war is indeed hell as
that rough Beast slouches towards its
destination this is as CP
2574 what appears from the outset to be
nothing more than a stone sculpture of a
lion comprised of sandstone and living
tissue standing at around 12 M tall SCP
2574 is much more than a mere statue in
fact it is a living creature after all
this is the SCP Foundation we're talking
about here where inanimate objects are
rarely inanimate at all or will at least
possess some form of anomalous property
setting apart anything ordinary and thus
drawing the interest of the foundation
SCP 2574 is similar in that regard and
not just for being a living statue
creature for one the anomaly is capable
of movement albeit at a gradual rate
that only progresses between 3 and 5 km
per day attempts by the foundation to
slow or halt the movement of SCP 2574
have been so far unsuccessful as it
seems that any obstacle placed in its
path are unable to deter it this
includes both man-made and naturally
occurring obstructions meaning there is
little that can be deployed to keep SCP
2574 physically contained even if a body
of water is in its path The Entity can
swim at a rate of between 2 and 3 km per
day and will normally either crush or
climb over any obstacle on land at the
previous annual budgeting meeting the
top mins of the foundation's accounting
department revealed to an infuriated 05
Council that SCP 2574 had been
responsible for an estimated total of
$25.3 million Us in Damages since its
Discovery the second most pressing
matter raised during that presentation
was that 112 deaths and a further 625
injuries the anomaly had also caused
despite pleas from the Ethics Committee
the foundation accountants were still
adamant that the cost of Damages was
more significant now a number of
prevailing questions might be plaguing
you regarding SCP
2574 for one what does this creature
want if it has freedom of movement and
can't be physically obstructed by the
foundation then is it just aimlessly
wandering free and causing want on
destruction or does it have a specific
want or goal it seeks to attain and for
another what does an almost 40ft tall
lion have to do with World War I well it
might surprise you to know that SCP 2574
has everything to do with the Great War
literally everything and as for a goal
it has one or rather it has a specific
destination it seems to be gradually
heading towards and if it makes it all
the way there it could spell disaster
for the entire globe in fact it could
plunge us back into one of the most
devastating conflicts the world has ever
seen can you guess which one SCP 257 74
possesses a wide array of latent
anomalous effects Beyond its General
functionality and movement above the
Sandstone line creature it is constantly
surrounded by A Flock of around 6,000
Birds of Prey any that find themselves
flying into the path of SCP 2574 are
assimilated into the growing flock
designated as SCP
25741 the mass of birds is fixated on
attacking SCP
2574 swooping low to strike at its
smooth muscle tissue with using their
beaks and Talons this however seems to
do little to deter SCP 2574 from making
progress as the anomaly constantly
regenerates from physical damage it
incurs from SCP 257
24-1 perhaps the most notable and
noticeable of SCP 2574 anomalous
properties is the effect it has on its
surroundings as it progresses towards
its destination the area around SC CP
2574 will undergo a physical
transformation in response to the
presence of the lion this transformation
results in the nearby region temporarily
becoming a World War I era combat zone
the ground below becomes riddled with
trenches carve through the Earth thick
muddy bogs and coiled razor sharp Nets
of barbed wire litter the area the
change triggered by SCP 2574 is hardly
just a cosmetic one either the
foundation have observed a number of
First first world war related
manifestations that occur in the wake of
SCP
2574 man-made land masses like trenches
and dugouts will appear nearby the front
lines reappearing after more than a
century Weaponry from the area is also
present following the arrival of SCP
2574 and this isn't just limited to
Firearms World War I was one of the
earliest large-scale conflicts in
history where in both sides deployed
aerial attacks through the use of byy
planes as well as chemical warfare as a
result signs of these can also be found
whenever SCP 2574 is nearby but again
the transformation as CP 2574 brings
about is not just limited to recreating
battlefields what some of you may not
know is the Great War did not so much
revolve around a core idealistic
difference between both sides as its
successor did instead the first world
war was a geopolitical grudge match
between large Global superpowers
attempting to make grandio displays of
their amassed military strength the
assassination of arch Duke France
Ferdinand of Austria at the hands of a
Serbian extremist group was the Catalyst
that set off a chain reaction of events
that ultimately led to War as a result
of this SCP 2574 is anomalous influence
also extends to the social and political
state of the areas it enters a country
that the sandstone leonine enti enters
will suffer a rapid change in its local
population's mentality the ordinary
people living there will start to
experience a great degree of discontent
towards their government while the
ruling powers of said country will
increase its use of force against its
own civilians this effect is more
noticeably potent when SCP 2574
interacts with countries that were
directly involved in the first world war
increasing levels of civil unrest and
discontentment among the population
these are often countered with
worryingly increased levels of police
brutality along with governments
enacting aggressive foreign policies and
sometimes antagonizing other countries
as if they are eager to fight these
effects don't necessarily worsen the
closer SCP 2574 gets to a particular
country but do seem to increase the more
it approaches its predicted destination
and where is that you may ask the
foundation have calculated that based on
SCP 2574 trajectory since its emergence
back in 2012 The Entity is headed for
the city of Saro the capital city of
Bosnia and heroina what possible reason
could SCP 2574 have for wanting to
venture towards this specific Bosnian
City well one cursory glance at the
history of Saro will give you the answer
it's where the assassination of arch
duuk France Ferdinand took place the
event commonly attributed with starting
the first world war the transformative
effects as CP 2574 has on its
surroundings began when the leonine
Leviathan first appeared and commenced
its journey toward Saro on December 24th
2012 since then the SCP Foundation has
been closely monitoring the Sandstone
creatures movements and attempting to
log all of the anomalous effects it has
had over the course of making its way
closer to the site of France ferdinand's
assassination over over 5,000 km away to
the east of kazakhstan's capital aana
SCP 2574 caused an unusual World War I
anomalous effect any written works
published in either Russian or kazak
began to randomly feature passages from
Irish poet WB Yates these extracts from
his body of work range from single
sentences to entire poems being featured
in other writers Publications regardless
of author or genre Yates for any one
unfamiliar was widely considered one of
the greatest Poets of the 20th century
however unlike the authors of numerous
poems and songs to come out of the first
world war WB Yates was never directly
involved in the conflict itself and
didn't write much about it barring a few
notable exceptions but more on him in a
moment when SCP 2574 approached Russia
things started to escalate clouds of
deadly chlorine gas an early World War I
chemical weapon began forming in rural
areas throughout Europe that couldn't be
dispersed for days at a time as soon as
the Towering anomaly got close enough
Russian military forces began launching
a series of drone strikes and aerial
bombardments targeting SCP
2574 when these attacks failed tensions
mounted with bordering countries the
situation only getting worse when it was
discovered through an intelligence leak
that Russia was planning a nuclear
strike against the creature a move that
likely could have spelled disaster for
the neighboring countries SCP 2574 of
course sustained no damage and continued
on its course given that they couldn't
physically contain SCP
2574 the foundation was forced to think
outside of the box when it came to
coming up with some kind of solution
there were already too many eyewitnesses
aware of the leonine leviathan's
existence to consider administering
amnestics even on a large scale the fact
was too many people are already knew
about SCP 2574 and would make such a
move pointless the best that the
foundation could do to combat if not
counteract the effects of SCP 2574 was
to work directly with governments
affected by the creatures World War One
transformative effects to try and repair
the damage left in the anomaly's wake
and ease the tension and violence it
caused it became the foundation's job to
deter any country planning an armed
military response to to the presence of
SCP
2574 as any such strike would endanger
both their military and civilian
populations while causing no damage to
the anomaly in the interest of trying to
solve the problems posed by SCP 2574
reverting parts of Europe to hellish
First World War era battlefields the
foundation made a rare agreement to
collaborate with another large
organization specializing in the
anomalous the global occult coalition
working directly with the GOC their goal
was to create a large scale mimetic
countermeasure that would effectively
reset the toll SC SCP 2574 had exacted
on global Psychology by altering
people's temperaments and creating mass
political unrest as it progressed
towards the Bosnian Capital however
given the tense history between the SCP
Foundation and the global occult
Coalition their attempts at creating a
mimetic countermeasure are still ongoing
since neither group wants the other to
engage them in full-scale mimetic
Warfare as such the proposed
countermeasure will consist of two parts
with neither organization being able to
replicate the other's half meanwhile SCP
2574 progress across Europe was
responsible for a number of other
significant changes physically socially
and politically recreating the
conditions of the first world war
poppies a flower that has since become
synonymous with the remembrance of the
conflict the began to grow in regions
within Russia where they wouldn't
naturally occur this included within
Urban locations the red flowers
sprouting in and around buildings as a
result of such a high-profile anomaly
causing such widespread unrest to spread
a number of religious cults centered
around SCP 2574 began to form while the
living descendants of World War I
veterans began suffering from Vivid
hallucinations that depicted their
ancestors firsthand experience of the
fighting these these Cults began to
amass more and more of those affected by
SCP
2574 the SCP Foundation was able to
observe some of the sermons delivered by
these religious cults who appeared to
view the public appearances of SCP
2574 as signs of an impending apocalypse
come to us and embrace your salvation
one cult leader exclaimed in a sermon
discover the words of the Prophet Yates
who spoke the sacred truth that all of
history is a spiral and that we have
spiraled outwards towards chaos learn
the true nature of the second coming it
appeared that some of these Cults viewed
the Poetry of wb8 as prophetic in
regards to SCP
2574 they would often reference the
second coming which interestingly was
the name of one of his poems written in
the aftermath of World War I yates's the
second coming refers to a rough Beast
slouching towards Bethlehem the SCP
Foundation has since uncovered some
erratic writings made by the poet before
his death that elude to Bethlehem
despite no record existing of him ever
traveling there it is believed that
Yates somehow figured out what SCP 2574
was and that The Closer it gets to its
destination the more civilization will
spiral further out of control towards
total allc consuming chaos further
research by the foundation also
uncovered a testimony made by gabilo PRP
the Serbian man responsible for
assassinating Arch duuk France Ferdinand
of Austria and thus sparking the first
world war PRP seems to have had had some
knowledge about SCP
2574 and apparently killed the arch
dukee as a way to begin the creature's
journey in order to make Society more
chaotic with SCP 2574 progressing
worryingly closer to the sight of France
ferdinand's assassination further chaos
rapidly began to spread anarchic
sentiments took hold of most of Europe
leading to an increased rate of violent
encounters between civilians and police
in many countries including Ireland
France Great Britain and Italy with a
number of these experiencing widespread
rioting in their major population
centers any government or political
party compelled by SCP 2574 to openly
exposed the same Anarchist sentiments
were soon seeing a rapid increase in
their public approval approval gaining
more popularity in polls than their
opposition as a result of these
heightened tensions between the public
and the government of their countries
assassination attempts of politicians
saw an alarming increase of around
60% SCP 2574 caused countries that had
existing hostile relations to engage in
armed skirmishes at their borders with
at least one of these battles occurring
every 2 weeks and each time threatening
to spark a much larger scale conflict
thanks to the anomaly's effects the
international tensions dissolving
alliances between countries and Adoption
of nationalism which were all factors
leading to the start of the Great War
were beginning to rapidly spread once
again by the time SCP 2574 was around
550 km from Saro people began
experiencing injuries common among
soldiers during World War I many
patients would die during surgery only
for their bodies to disappear shortly
afterwards conflict erupt between
Ireland and England and as SCP 2574
entered Bosnia and heroina many began to
report suffering intense dreams about
the anomaly a number of these reports
seem to state that SCP 2574 was
attempting to communicate with them and
multiple websites began logging the
Sandstone Lion's appearance in their
dreams and things will only get worse
the closer SCP 2574 gets to SAR Eva
SCP 2574 contains the raw energy of
World War I one of the most catastrophic
events in human history a global
conflict with a death toll in the tens
of millions the SCP Foundation estimates
it'll reach the sight of France
ferdinand's assassination within a month
and from that point given the effect
it's had on the rest of Europe there's
only one likely outcome when that rough
Beast slouches towards its ultimate
destination War the helicopter lurched
and rumbled as it made its descent
through the veran insk mountain range
conditions were harsh with Fierce winds
ripping Through The Valleys at any point
a blizzard threatened to strike just
about managing to touch down mobile task
force Lambda 9 was glad to be out of the
vehicle even if it meant stepping into
kneee snow there were eight operatives
in total early reconnaissance suggested
that they were the only people present
within a 5 K radius at least that's
certainly what they hoped L9 operatives
1 through six all made their way up
through the mountain pass leaving seven
and eight guarding the chopper this was
a simple reconnaissance mission they
would need to search the bunker for any
signs of Life gather Intel and get out
hopefully before the snowstorm hit all
eight of them were kitted out with the
foundation's kter grade Cutting Edge
anti- cionic plating the operatives had
all been chosen carefully with L 9-1 the
leader being an experienced Soldier
serving 11 years in the unit he had
capable psionic Powers himself and
approached L 9-2 who showed some of the
same gifts all of a sudden as the group
rounded the final pass and caught sight
of the facility both one and two
experienced severe migraines battered by
the Russian wind they had no choice but
to get to the bunker as fast as possible
it looked relatively unassuming a small
concrete slab sitting amongst the
mountains the six of them gathered
around on either side of the doors as
number three forced his way inside
following standard breaching Maneuvers
the rest of the team followed suit
charging in through the open doorway and
immediately tipping forward into an
abyss they all landed hard side by side
on the slope some of them rolling down
clattering against each other and
eventually skidding to a stop very
gingerly the groups started to get back
to their feet and catch their breath as
the wind had been knocked out out out of
all of them they weren't in a research
facility at all the Soviet concrete
walls they hadd been expecting the old
computers and the lab equipment were all
missing instead they were standing in a
void infinite and white with no seeming
end in any direction beneath their feet
and curling up above them was an
enormous double helix a rainbow of
colors weaving in and out of one another
it was like they had found themselves
standing on an enormous strand of DNA
floating all around them were glowing
orbs of light none of them could tell
how near or far these orbs were they
could have been close enough to reach
out and touch or they could have been on
the other side of the universe and
slowly one by one they noticed the
doorway that they had come in through it
was perpendicular to the double helix
and floating about 3 m above their heads
through it they could see the snowy
Russian Mountains their only chance of
Escape four murmured something about
needing to leave one argued back at him
they had no idea whether that door was
real or an illusion they had no idea if
they would even be able to pass through
it besides it was 3 m above their heads
and floating out over the void it was
risky but for didn't care much about
receiving permission taking a few steps
back further down the double helix to
get a good runup he braced himself and
sprinted as fast as he could before
jumping and reaching for the open
doorway it was as if gravity was
suddenly much stronger as soon as he
stepped off the double helix four was
wrenched downwards tumbling and spinning
accelerating faster and faster he let
out a petrified scream that sent the
other operatives cowering there was no
bottom at least not as far as they could
see or hear for's body just got smaller
and smaller and his screams quieter and
quieter for several minutes until the
agents couldn't hear him anymore and yet
inside the heads of one and two the
psionic members of the group that's
screaming sound only seemed to grow
louder December 25th
1962 a man walked briskly through the
West Berlin train station he' shaved his
head the night before and trimmed his
beard down to a thick mustache dark
sunglasses covered his eyes and a fedora
was tipped forward he hoped that his
limp was convincing as he shuffled his
way through the crowds one advantage of
wearing dark sunglasses in the middle of
winter was that he could constantly scan
the faces of those around him look for
anybody who looked Russian his train had
been delayed an hour outside of Berlin
the train had ground to a halt German
police officers had walked the length of
the carriages checking everyone's
tickets and passports it felt like an
eternity the man was too old by this
point to attempt to run away besides
running through rural Germany in the
snow didn't sound like the best plan so
he stuck to his cover story and hoped
against hope that the fake passport he
bought would be convincing enough enough
fortunately for him the officer checked
it he looked to be about 18 years old
the man doubted that the boy would know
a Russian passport if it was signed by
Nikita kushev himself but shuffling
through the station his feeling of
unease grew Russian deserters had been
poisoned all around him for the prior 15
years a number of his own colleagues had
mysteriously gone missing after feeling
disenfranchised by the Soviet agenda he
was such a high-profile Target that
there was no way the k GB wasn't
actively hunting him down at that very
moment he clutched the briefcase tightly
and made his way out of the station his
plan had been to call a taxi but now the
prospect of being alone in an anonymous
vehicle with only one other person
terrified him his best protection would
be to stay out in the open as much as
possible he would walk to the British
Embassy or rather he'd pretend to limp
there Lambda 9 operatives number seven
and eight stood by the helicopter
shivering their team had been missing
for hours now and they could see the
blizzard slowly covering the mountain
range like a blanket before long it
would reach them if their helicopter got
buried by anything more than a couple of
inches all hopes of evacuating back to
base would be dashed as soon as their
team had gone through the doors into the
facility all radial contact with them
had been cut off the foundation had
suspected that the bunker would be
heavily insulated but if that were the
case surely one of them would have
stepped outside to resume radio contact
and report what they had found so far
then all of a sudden seven went limp he
remained standing but his head and
shoulders slumped forward as if he'd
fallen asleep perhaps he had been
standing out here for too long Aid was
about to Rouse him when suddenly seven
started talking hello8 can you hear me
it's one are you there the conversation
moved quickly somehow one had been able
to reach out to Seven's mind and
temporarily take control in order to use
him as a mouthpiece to communicate with
the foundation over the radio this kind
of contact would normally have been well
beyond what one would have been capable
of but he explained that as soon as they
had entered the facility both he and two
had felt their powers growing
immeasurably the foundation asked for a
situation report and one updated them
about what had happened to four trying
to escape through the door he jumped and
fell through the abyss but what was more
sickening was that they had seen for
again all of a sudden they had started
to hear his screams physically not
psionically and he had fallen past them
just off to their right almost within
touching distance having decided that it
was too risky to attempt an escape as
four had done the group of them made the
decision to travel further down into the
facility descending along the Helix for
the next 3 hours s is unresponsive he
stands there limp in the snow hunched
forward and not speaking despite eight
and the foundation's best attempts to
wake him command we found something the
Helix branches off a bit there's a
doorway there I can see inside it looks
like a lab of some kind we can walk to
it hopefully it's a way out command sent
authorization for them to proceed and so
they did one reported that it appeared
that they were back in the real world
the abstract shapes and colors the
infinite void was gone they were in a
Soviet research lab there was medical
equipment everywhere syringes and jars
full of well maybe it's best not to know
what was in in them as Lambda 9 walked
through the facility checking every
corner before rounding out they felt a
profound sense of unease surely enough
that feeling was warranted rounding the
corner one found some human remains the
man appeared to have been a researcher
at one point his brains were now
stretched out and stuck to the walls
like Silly Putty what the hell happened
here safely on British soil the man who
had defected from the Soviet Union sat
in the interview room chewing his bottom
lip he had spent so much time focusing
on how he would escape with his life
that he hadn't spared much thought for
what he would say once he was on the
other side they had codenamed him Iceman
but he didn't feel particularly cold at
that moment he felt nervous but he did
his best to hide it I was a project
manager in the psychotronics division of
the main intelligence directorate I
oversaw project Redline which was
commissioned by Joseph Stalin following
the second world war and before he knew
what he was doing he told his
interviewer everything over 20 million
Soviets had died during the second world
war their death toll eclips that of any
other country Iceman had witnessed it
all so when Stalin had come to him with
the task of creating an ultra powerful
psychic weapon something that could
convert the entire world population to
adopt Marxism leninism the man had his
reservations activating a device like
that could trigger a war even deadlier
than either of the two already
experienced that Century he was part of
Gru division P the Russian arm of Highly
classified experimental research
conferring with his team they devised a
plan they would argue they needed
absolute secrecy to carry out their work
even away from the watching eyes of the
KGB rather than create a weapon they
would create a tool for peace instead of
promoting the values of Communism they
would create a psychic tool to dampen
Humanity's inclination towards violence
and aggression
their method would be brutal but un
necessary evil in short their theory was
the psychic mind is often limited by the
human body a young child could have
incredible psychic potential but their
physical limitations would hold them
back from exercising it therefore they
needed to separate mind from body and
they had just the trick for that
traumatic disassociation they would take
a young gifted psychic and tear out
their mind in order to transfer that
mind into the body of of a controllable
Avatar Iceman explained that none of
them could have expected how much fate
would look favorably on them just 2
years prior the KGB had captured and
brought in a set of triplets for them
the triplets were incredibly rare
conjoined at both the head and the Torso
with three arms and six legs it was a
miracle they were still alive so Iceman
and his team set to work immediately
they dosed the triplets up with as many
mind-altering chemicals as they could
physically endure before electrocuting
them for prolonged periods whilst
reading antiv violent manifestos to them
it worked the triplets mind
disassociated and the Soviets were able
to capture it Iceman was not forthcoming
about what they did with the mind or
where they transferred it all he
explained was that it worked they took
the weapon to the norog gulag 50,000 of
the most vicious criminals known to men
Luther murderers Psychopaths dropped
their makeshift knives and refused to
move an inch even as we through the
gates of the camp wide open we did that
the final test was on Nikita Kev and
John F Kennedy from thousands of
kilometers away they activated project
Redline and influenced the two world
leaders at the height of the Cuban
Missile Crisis war was averted but crev
was Furious he removed the entire team
killing a number of them and began to
weaponize project Redline if they could
fire it at an advancing Army they'd
never lose a single soldier ever again
to do this it needed to be stronger they
were to implant the Consciousness into
another subject torture them further and
disassociate again amplifying the
psychic abilities mobile task force
Lambda 9 were stuck in the facility the
blizzard had been so strong that seven
and eight had to return to base the
previous night and come back having
spent a night lost in wandering through
the Helix descending deeper and deeper
the team had noticed that the world
around them was getting darker
periodically they could hear Force
screaming and falling past them once
again before dropping out of sight again
beneath them they had tried to catch him
to pull him back but he was always just
Out Of Reach desperate to be saved seven
and 8 returned and their psychic puppet
radio contact was resumed with command
the team found another door searching
through it they were horrified to find
their own corpses floating in the air in
front of them dressed up in lab coats
just like the scientists from the levels
above them their brains were stretching
out and lying together in some kind of
web yet further down the Helix they f
found another door one and three decided
to go inside leaving the rest of the
team standing on the Helix ready to
catch four if he fell past again this
time two was in contact with command
through his psychic link to the men by
the chopper he soon reported hearing
Four's screams getting closer and closer
the group stood around ready to catch
him there he is I can see him he's
definitely Falling Towards us yeah I see
it too command there's something up with
for it looks like he's spread eagled his
arms are stretched out he's he's
screaming it's not getting louder it's
getting flatter there would be no
further contact with two five and six by
the time one and three returned from
scouting out the room they were alone
one couldn't even sense the presence of
any of their squadmates anymore they had
no option but to continue to descend the
Helix into the darkness the smell of
burning flesh filled their noses The
Echoes of death were all around them
voices cried out in pain and fear and
then new voices speaking in russan
cut over the top stop it give in don't
resist resisting is bad you'll be
punished if you resist begin electrical
discharge 500 volts 3 amps increase
voltage every minute the operatives had
no choice but to listen to the memory of
the triplets being tortured not just the
sounds but the emotions that flood them
those weren't someone else's memories
anymore they were becoming their own and
just as they saw into the mind of the
tripet
the triplets saw them in return command
it's trying to open me up like it did
everyone else but I can see into it it's
learning from us it knows all about me
the squad the foundation they're almost
on me it's it's the conjunction the
scientists the monsters that made this
thing the ones it knew before it died
was that they wanted it to conjunct it
wants to make us part of it don't come
back here it wants to make the whole
world part of it and at that moment the
entirety of mobile task force Lambda 9
dropped dead in that same moment a
multicolored sphere of energy 5 km wide
appeared over the facility dwarfing the
mountains around it designated SCP 2664
D for years the foundation dropped
psionically dampening materials and
psionically stumped d-class Personnel
into the sphere in hopes of slowing its
growth no other containment measures
could be acted upon that was until 1300
hours on the 25th of December December
2000 Christmas Day SCP 2664 daa suddenly
fluctuated releasing an enormous amount
of pionic energy that resulted in the
brain death of all humans within a 200
km radius the following day at 17700
hours a global cult Coalition satellite
launched a spherical payload right into
the heart of SCP 2664 daa for 13 minutes
tremendous amounts of radiation were
detected emanating from inside the
sphere before just as suddenly as it had
appeared SCP 2664 daa disappeared
entirely leaving just the payload in its
place before the foundation was able to
recover the payload it launched into the
atmosphere and was lost subsequent
reconnaissance operations to the site
have confirmed no abnormal radioactive
or psionic readings to all intents and
purposes SCP 2664 appears to be gone as
such the file has been marked as
neutralized long long may it stay that
way there was blood in the water but at
least the screaming had stopped it had
been an ill-advised party boat floating
out in Dangerous Waters where a bachelor
party full of rich and naive men had
ignored every warning some had told them
don't you know that pirates operate in
these Waters others had cautioned you
might get confused for pirates and shot
down by military boats nobody had
expected The Impossible monster that had
actually killed all 10 people who'd gone
out there on that warm ocean night but
in the chaos that unfolded the day after
they would find out a cargo ship
carrying hundreds of millions of dollars
with of products and valuable raw
materials was scheduled to cross those
same Waters if they could have gone any
other way they would have but with
corporate shipping deadlines to reach
they couldn't afford to take the scenic
route and potentially add over an entire
week to an already long trip the cargo
ship would need to take the the risk
they would need to face the Pirates on
their own turf if it came to that
meanwhile on a number of secret
compounds on land the Pirates were
preparing their corrupt government
shipping sources had given them a
valuable tip about the coming ship and
they were doing everything they could in
order to ensure this flagrant Act of
piracy would be successful they loaded
fuel into the tanks of their speedboats
they clicked magazines full of
armor-piercing bullets into their AK-47s
they slipped on bulletproof body armor
and clipped grenades to their belts they
were a terrifying force to be reckoned
with but they had no idea that within a
few hours they would be encountering
something far more dangerous you see
strange things had been happening on
some of the world's coastlines it
started with Surfers fool hearty
sun-kissed Thrill Seekers with an
addiction to catching the biggest waves
possible of course there are plenty of
surfers who get claimed by the Sea every
year it is knocking occupational hazard
especially for fledgling Surfers but the
mysterious circumstances of all the
workers had something in common blood in
the water of course it didn't stop with
Surfers anyone who swam a few feet
further than the edge of the water
seemed to be at risk lonely Moonlight
swimmers went first but it didn't take
long for whole families to start
disappearing in the waves a few here a
few there nothing that most people even
noticed just a whole bunch of
unconnected isolated tragedies the sea
is a cruel mistress though when looking
at these cases nobody ever considered
that something else entirely could be
behind all these terrifying
disappearances but back to the cargo
ship making its way across the turbulent
Waters and those Waters were indeed
turbulent far choppier than the forecast
had predicted the waves were huge
towering even but that was no excuse to
delay their important mission
their comms had recently received a
communic from the local government about
the missing party boat and all its
occupants assumed dead the previous
night Pirates most likely the cargo ship
had come prepared for this eventuality
the company sponsoring their efforts had
lost too much time and money to let
their ships be sitting ducks floating
goodie bags for violent criminals that's
why they'd spent a little extra money on
a precaution heavily armed mercenaries
patrolling the ship ready to kill in
order to protect their boss's products
the scene is set for a blood bath and
certain things out there in the deep
love a good blood bath the Pirates ready
to make a lot of money by any means
necessary loaded into their ships and
speedboats their assault rifles slung on
their backs they took to the waters
howling battlecries as they zeroed in on
the cargo ship across the Bucking waves
they prepared to fire but they didn't
expect their target to fire back with no
mercy The Mercenaries ran ran to the
edge of the boat and started firing down
on the smaller boats surrounding them
with machine guns several Pirates went
down chalk full of bullets dead before
they could even figure out what was
going on as their bodies sank amidst the
waves their blood floated on the surface
like big red plumes while the Pirates
were shocked at the resistance they
weren't unprepared you don't get to
become the rulers of this particularly
tough part of the ocean without being
ready to give it even harder than you
can take it in accordance with this the
Pirates loaded up the handful of RPGs
they brought out with them and fired
their deadly payloads at the side of the
cargo ship boom boom boom the ship was
rocked by explosions knocking over some
of the many mercenaries standing on the
hole some fell screaming down into the
water where Pirates quickly cut them
down with bursts of Ruthless gunfire but
one mercenary who fell off the back of
the boat got lucky or unlucky depending
on your perspec perspective no pirate
spotted him potentially leaving him safe
and sound until he noticed a large wave
coming towards him it took more than a
little water to frighten this hardened
Soldier of Fortune until he saw
something nightmarish hiding in the dark
the flashh of white fangs and an ivory
jaw it hinged open and bore down on him
as the wave prepared to crash the
mercenary screamed and after the wave
hit him he was gone meanwhile the
violent battle between the mercenaries
on the cargo ship and the Pirates trying
to claim it raged on using grappling
hooks the Pirates were climbing up onto
the hull having disabled the back Rudder
with sustained gunfire and targeted
bombing the ship was soon suffused with
Bloodshed as pirates and mercenaries
gunned each other down in bloody combat
men were falling left and right but
there always seemed to be more little by
little as each man fell there was more
and more blood in the water out in the
depths as a storm began to rage and the
waves whipped and roared
something hungry could smell and taste
the blood one boat full of pirates kept
circling the cargo ship like a Hungry
Shark one worked the engine with
practiced efficiency while another three
aimed AK-47s up at the ship waiting for
the moment when another unfortunate
mercenary stuck up his head ready to
receive a bullet but their true enemy
wasn't even on the ship it was sneaking
up behind them only the man working the
speedboats engine spotted it before it
was too late a wave rose out of the sea
moving with a speed that shocked even
this veteran seaf farer at first he
thought nothing of it too busy to keep
out of the range of mercenary bullets he
was hardly the type to worry about
getting wet and then he saw the teeth as
the wave Rose well above his height and
only a few feet away he saw something
impossible floating in the water a shape
he'd been seeing hanging above the
fireplace in a bar he'd been frequenting
for years the jaws and teeth of a great
white shark perhaps it was just refu
from a dead shark floating in the water
that was the most reasonable explanation
right but if that was the case why would
the Jaws be spreading further apart as
though ready to receive him he screamed
so loud that his crewmates first assumed
he'd taken a bullet but when they turned
around they saw the truth a huge wave
was crashing down on them and they saw
the teeth not just one set the one that
the engine man had seen But A different
set of teeth for each of them Hungry
Shark mouths without sharks bearing down
they all screamed their desperate sounds
of Terror blending into an incoherent
chorus before being cut off by the crash
of the Waves the boat was wrecked empty
and Blood Stained when the water
dissipated sinking lifelessly to the
bottom of the ocean but of course the
worst was yet to come the anomaly in the
waves was ins satiated all the
mercenaries and Pirates it had taken so
far were just the appetizer and now it
was ready for the main course everyone
now on the cargo ship pirate mercenary
and sailor caught in between who was
fighting and even dying for money had no
idea what was coming the wave rumbled
and Rose behind the ship getting taller
and taller and taller until even the
giant vessel looked like a toy boat in
its wake in the darkness of the wave
hundreds of pairs of nashing shark jaws
the sharp edges of their teeth
glistening the wave fell upon the ship
sending flesh eating water coursing
through every nook and cranny when the
water cleared there wasn't a single
Survivor the ship irreparably broken
sank to a metal graveyard down below
nobody in the normal world would even
know what happened for those with a fear
of sharks and deep water this particular
anomaly is a living Nightmare and one
that the French division of the SCP
Foundation has encountered with
unsettling frequency it's been recorded
manifesting off a number of different
coastlines and who even knows how often
it's manifested out in deeper waters
despite its uclid classification
containing this anomaly has been no mean
feat it's involved shutting down a
number of coastlines completely on the
pretense of animal research the
administration of Class A amnestics to
Witnesses and class b amnestics to
victims as well as a complicated
disinformation campaign to suppress
photos and reports of the phenomenon
online but even with all of these
containment procedures in place many
have still lost their lives to the jaws
of SCP 054 dfr or the Great White Wave
by the foundation's current estimations
recorded attacks by the Great White Wave
have been fatal 68% of the time with
survivors often experiencing wounds
consistent with those of an abnormally
bad shark attack in case our opening
case study didn't clue you in the Great
Great White Wave is a set of ravenous
shark jaws most closely resembling the
karadon karius or great white shark
manifesting inside ocean waves any waves
over 4 M tall can become a host to a
Great White Wave event with their
theoretically being no upper limit to
the size of a wave capable of causing
this kind of anomalous catastrophe the
power of the Great White Wave spite is
also directly proportional to the size
of the wave it manifests on two meaning
that in theory a tsunami playing host to
the Great White Wave could devour an
entire town while every attack that the
foundation has failed to prevent is of
course a tragedy the number of attacks
has allowed the foundation to uncover
some extremely interesting data for
example while attacks Could Happen
anywhere at Sea they're most common in
the 250 M ocean radius around a
coastline when a human or non-aquatic
animal is present in the attack zone
Great White waves move at three times
the speed of a normal wave in pursuit of
its unfortunate prey the Great White
Wave isn't picky about its prey either
divers swimmers and even aquatic
Vehicles like boats or jet skis have
been devoured though the waves seem to
show a particular preference for Surfers
which is gnarly in the typical sense but
not in the sense that Surfers say it the
ghostly shark jaws will only become
visible next to the part of the wave
closest to the victim meaning that they
often aren't spotted until it's too late
but that doesn't mean it can't consume
multiple victims at once as you saw with
the unfortunate Sailors and pirates in
our opening story many sets of Jaws can
manifest in the case of having multiple
victims to Devour the actual consumption
occurs as the wave crashes down upon the
victim so the only recorded way to
survive being on the wrong side of the
Great White Wave is to dive into the
water before the wave crashes the French
division of the foundation conducted a
series of experiments in hopes of
understanding the Dynamics of the Great
White Wave which had results both
encouraging and disturbing based on
non-anomalous shark ability to
electromagnetically sense blood from
extreme distances the foundation wanted
to see if the same could be said for the
Great White Wave after pouring several
liters of animal blood into the water of
an affected area they found that a Great
White Wave regularly manifested within 2
minutes crashing down and devouring the
affected blood however an extension of
this experiment found an alarming result
the same amount of human blood attracted
a Great White Wave in under 60 seconds
even a small amount of human blood
attracted a Great White Wave
significantly faster than a large amount
of animal blood interestingly
non-anomalous great white sharks will
rarely ever attack humans on purpose
whenever they do it's often because they
mistook a swimming or surfing human for
a seal their natural prey you'll often
find that most shark attack victims are
only bitten once a common shark behavior
known as a testing bite once the shark
realizes that it isn't eating a seal it
will quickly move along yes this
probably won't make the person with a
shark bite taken out of them feel any
better but the shark didn't truly want
to eat them great white Waves by
contrast enjoy eating humans
significantly more than animals but that
doesn't mean they won't eat all kinds of
animals several Maritime birds were
eaten by a great white wave when they
flew in front of the wave that was over
4 M tall we suppose the Great White Wave
has never heard the salty old Sea Dog
tale that it's bad luck to kill a
seabird the foundation discovered a few
useful things from their experiments if
you want to avoid getting eaten by the
Great White Wave you should avoid
getting into the water if you're
suffering from any kind of injury
wounded people are four times as likely
to be the victims of attacks with the
Great Wide wave manifesting in less than
60 seconds you can also improve your
chances of surviving by following Sam
Neil's advice from Jurassic Park don't
move move a muscle movement especially
panicked thrashing has a tendency to
lure this unique aquatic Predator into
your vicinity But Here Comes the
disappointing part other than staying in
a landlock area there's basically
nothing else you can do in order to stop
a Great White Wave event weapons have
proven completely ineffective with the
bullets of even the highest caliber
weapons simply disappearing into the
wall of water stealth Beyond avoiding
movement is also ineffective no attempt
to camouflage the smell of humans has
been effective in helping them evade the
detection of the Great White Wave you
can probably imagine how many
unfortunate DCL classes got devoured in
the process of finding that one out the
Great White Wave is a disturbing
reminder that perhaps we shouldn't worry
about what lks in the deep ocean when
nothing has a greater capacity to
destroy us than the unimaginable power
of the ocean itself now go check out SCP
3760 like a doll's eyes and SCP 144 9
Dreamtime whale shark for more